de notre ami ali reza et ben voilà elle
est ici la partie on l'a en face de nous
martinez d'or ouais donc là on nage dans
le turf quoi
territoire connu un âge d'or évidemment
que mv elle joue que des pots à jouer
pendant très longtemps donc ça va être
très intéressant alors on va avoir le
micro est ce que ça va ouais ça a l'air
de passer femme je suis juste en train
de régler les niveaux puisque tu as pas
la même voix que je relate dans ce que
black duck ou 4 c 5 km trois des six des
quatre manches cavalli branles d'anne
frank ou méfaits rapporte qu est étroite
et a6 donc
la neige d'or et bat dépouilles se
bornent
il en a absolument rien à faire et ça y
est il revient on va rester un petit peu
sur la caméra pour l'ouverture les a mis
dans le sens où on est ici sur du très
connu à la nage d'offres c'est
l'ouverture principal de maxime vachier
lagrave à
et ici il a joué f3 donc f3 fab c'est
pas forcément le coût principal même si
dans cette nage d'or j'ai envie de dire
quasiment tout est jouable je rappelle
plus le nombre de coups possibles mais
y'a quoi il ya fouet trois fous j'ai 5 h
trois tours j'ai un f3 damev trois fois
oui mais possible h4 deux greffes 4 et 4
way à 4 à 4 3 à 3
à 3 j'ai déjà vu aussi manger 3
évidemment oui ou non - ouais
tv3
je vais repasser sur sur le vent juste
pour que vous voyez bien tous ces coups
là sont réellement
possible même si rare alors à temps
habib sy
tous les coups sont possibles tous les
coups du tennis alors lui lâché moi je
passe on va dire ouais je crois on l'a
dit à 6 donc tu la joues et f3 à la f3
ça permet de protéger le pion et 2
contres la callas bon en fait je sais
pas pourquoi il faut caruana fêtera
aussi donc il est d'ailleurs un truc d
une raison pourquoi ils font est propre
tout faux
mais en gros l'idée de 3,7 fois 300 kg 4
laurent brossard transposant du foot
oui et ça c'est la partie que mathieu a
analysé juste avant mais ouanna duda
ouais je crois qu'ils avaient pu fausser
th 5 faut vérifier je crois
qu'il faut ça donc il est le principal
sur sa case n'est pas qu'il vient de
faire d'amd de près par le grac donc ont
censuré grandes lignes
de ces engins d maroc
j'ai envie de te dire retournons un
anorak et oui sur la caméra les deux
hommes connaissent un âge d'or qui
peuvent être préparés aisément jusqu'au
25e 26e coup ça fait vraiment trop loin
et pourquoi une position recomposée et
bon voilà ta de secours f3 explique
pourquoi et là ça supporte sur quatre
donc si jamais il ya un coup comme b5 b4
chasse le cavaly c3 est long plus de
question à se poser nos rangs ce qui a
éveillé toute façon va se diriger vers
la case des 5
et donc f3 sera-ce un deuxième manche
du micro femme
tu parles ok mais je vais avoir à la
verticale à l'aller trop plancher comme
ça peut-être fallu bref où tu sois
proche globalement parce qu'en fait tu
t'entends t'envoie patate avoir en
profondeur
la socialité dans le jeu c'est ça c'est
ça
la tête je pense que tu es très bien
faut juste que tu sois proche en fait je
le vois dit me gêne dans mon regard mais
c'est pas mal je m'habitue vois un truc
dont on est très dangereux
après tu peux le baisser un peu tu peux
tu peux aussi de mettre un peu plus bas
quoi mais après ça faut que tu règles
non là ça va ça en emmerde hannah je
pense que tu es bien là
après tain genre daigle quoi donc grand
roque ont rejoué
bon là pour le moment on réussit la
théorie ali riza et nepomniachi rock et
b17 norman
bon set j'étais à temps
après peut-être un petit coup droit bien
ou qu'on serait jouable mais les caps
et encore des dizaines de milliers de
parties
on sait pas ce qui va être jouée là faut
se dire que tu es que c'est quasiment
comme une position d co 16 après des 4
en termes d'avancées dans la théorie je
veux dire par là que c'est une position
faut pas dire oui on est déjà au 11e
coup les joueurs s'approche de la fin de
ce qu'ils connaissent
lassé des positions qui sont tellement
concrètes il faut vraiment connaître
loin et fort
si chacun se souvient bien soit
inattendu
exactement
alors
question un peu bête mais la phase
retour se joue dans la foulée où il ya
une pause entre les deux phases nom
s'ajoute à la suite en fait il ya juste
du repos tous les trois jours ouais
c'est l'an dernier et qui a vu la pause
mais qui n'étaient pas voulues par le
train c'est parce qu il en soit en
attendant il se joue tous d'affilée
peut-être le sicilien départage où s'est
tenu le 4 et le 5 les départageront
saura de tout ranger de carcassonne si
karzaï n'accepte français de l'accès
on dit toujours bas qui avaient
exactement la même position qu'elle est
réservé sur l'échiquier aujourd'hui ali
riza joue l'ouverture festi'jeunes
ventures que baky seconde depuis des
années vous allez me faire croire que ba
qui ne seront pas les résa on va
continuer à entretenir cette légende un
temps content qu'on le peut
car à 12,2 pour le moment c'est
des positions auxquelles le cavalier par
ailleurs
mais pas les verts à 4 au 6 mai en fait
c'est logique ce que sur cavale et h5 tu
veux cavaliers g3
vite
ça suit à
des grandes variantes
disque a encore 2006 en partie dans la
base à aimer à ses fins
c'est juste une grande position en
réalité un voit
là les joueurs n'ont pas encore réfléchi
un seul cours
le coup plus jouissive onge à turbine
avec moi quatre
matches quatre j'imagine aussi roi b1 et
jetteront kg 3
après tout et tout est faisable en deux
parties avec inna nom de
hockey effet quattro
on l'avait analysé d'ailleurs ensemble
dans les nôtres on a cinq
écoutes on va voir
après les réserves jusqu'à maintenant il
a toujours été très bien préparé donc ça
ça donne confiance d'un autre côté né
peut encore avoir sa prépa du
championnat du monde mais à la nage dans
ce n'est pas vraiment l'ouverture de
prédilection magnus carlsen alors est ce
qu'ils ont vraiment travaillé la nage de
hrw à fond ça mais enfin ça m'aurait
étonné de voir une âge d'orb de carl
scène
comprenez pas
et
tu peux pas vraiment faire d'impasse
états du monde
genre s'arrêter quand même temps a été
surprenant
sur toutes ces insuffisances être
physiquement il a fait plus de 4 de
laquelle la quatre
voies la ligne c'était quoi la ligne
principale c'est à 4 et sur pions prend
aussi si on prend b3 puis on prend 17
qui on prend 1,2 et regardent ils se
lèvent ouais je sais qu'il l'a surpris
d'ailleurs il a quand même une belle
paire et alireza parce que la nage enfin
l'huile un répertoire à lire et sa très
variés contre quatre et ils jouent
larmes principal de dépôt fin l'une des
armes principales de dépôt contre 4 donc
c'est quand même assez assez courageux
de sa part juste pour dire que tous tes
90 à 4 coups
et qui a aidé 4
comprend qu'il valait prend b3
et si tu vas là-bas mais je crois qu'il
existe un
donc b3
ait eu veut plus on prend 1,2 à un down
on croit
b12 qui font ces deux études au nombre
des trois pourquoi mahmoud abbas oui et
c'est l'été la fameuse partie mais je
crois qu'il est utile et bien ça être b5
ça c'est la ligne bon bah faut connaître
encore plus loin bien sûr mais ça donne
plutôt ce genre de truc est bon c'est la
deuxième à l'audience
à noter un que je me répète mais ce
genre de prépa avec kaka très aimé des
cas tout cas les joueurs peuvent
réellement connaître ce genre
d'opposition jusqu'à la fin
vous entendez mal fabre helmand bah je
sais pas si c'est juste un message de 30
ans
en fait moi je vois sur le retour
peut-être des fois tu parle un peu moins
fort faut que tu t'habitues
on mettre un micro casque
[Musique]
c'est une me baisser mois encore un peu
au présentateur plus comme ça mais faut
je les rechanges et pour ce qu'on m'a
dit
un peu moins fort mais c'est quand même
nom mais en fait je vais je peux juste
baissé bon son on va voir la règle c'est
l'équilibré comme il faut
les gens horizon peinture je pense que
verticale comme ça où comme ça je
mettrai qu'à ça et je vais très vraiment
tranchant comme ça quoi moi je mettrais
comme ça allez on va tourner comme ça
mais il faut pas que tu hésites a
vraiment à parler tout le temps forts
essayez de gueuler non-stop en fait
poussé quatre fous ces cartes jouées
vrai
bon en soi ce à un coût relativement
normal vous ces quatre peut-être acquis
le rouge
avec les blancs et j'ai trop revient non
jam nasa 4 non juste abbas et l'idée
ton corps horizontale
faut coller comme qu'avant sa bataille
mais je sais pas moi je parle j'ai
tellement l'habitude de pages je parle
plus formant le stream global mans ouais
c'est l'habitude en fait ça je le fais
naturellement
ouais donc je regarde juste quelques
parties jouées par email ou par
correspondance les blancs ont
principalement fait qu'ils aient les g3
vous prend
à chaud en a quatre cavalières alors
donc il découvrit mais
sa vie peut-être qu'un jour on
ressentira par par ces deux
et sur un coup comme à troyes tu fais 3
pardon mais dans l'autre sens désolé
et tu te dis que tu te feras jamais
attaqué sur case noire bon après je pars
et elle est partie dans leur globalité
un juge s'était un peu
et mais par contre c'était parti à ses
anciennes genre 2008 c'est surprenant
ressources et 4
après c'est souvent les prépas les plus
dangereuses
après donc évidemment l'autre coup c'est
roy bien ce que comme ça sur un cachet
que le client sait
voir en tout cas n'est peau qui
réfléchit c'est une bonne nouvelle un
temps j'ai envie de le remettre en
grande qu'à mme
hilal un prix il donne l'impression de
quelqu'un qui a un fichier en tout cas
et qui essaye de se rappeler je trouve
mais en fait il peut pas ne jamais avoir
regardé le coup c'est un des groupes
logique hockey à 4 tout le monde fait
mais je te demande
encore une belle prépa d'alireza wet
dans ce tournoi pour le moment il est il
joue parfaitement
non niveau pré passait très bien
c'est excellent bref on va voir ce que
ça donne concrètement en fait ce fossé 4
soit intéressant mais la position après
qu'alizé trois prises et fait un prêt
fin à quatre cavaliers doit être
critique s'est regardé et donc voir
après ce qui se passe plus en détail
quoi
bon bah écoute tu veux qu'on regarde un
peu d'autres partis ouais on peut bien
sûr moscou
bref ce châtiment on n'est pas au même
si bon allemand évoque la passe toujours
su
donc la deuxième partie
rogozine
pedragosa
ouais donc ça c'est la partie dingli
rennes contre caruana
donc il s'est passé quoi il s'est passé
des quatre qui réfléchissent et 4,6 km
trois des cinq essais trois fous b4
comme tu disais damas quatre pour
attirer le carillon ses 6 e 3 roc dames
ces deux cavaliers à 5 c 5 b6 et c ding
qui semble être surpris
c'est rare en reprenant du plat du
nouveau des grands singes ouais il n'y a
que deux partis dans la petite base
pas étonnante caruana
très bien préparée et qui vient avec une
petite idée qui a mené à cinq qui met la
pression sur sur ces quatre ans grosse
je pense que tu aimerais bien que les
blancs sûr qu'elle est à 5 face et prend
des cinq
mais peut-être un gars que l'option
débarrasse des problèmes de trousser
vite il pourra sortir pour
tous at-il banque ding il a fait ces
cinq ici ferme le jeu et veut peut-être
faire des a3b 4 et sur quoi sur quoi
notre roi n'affaiblisse immédiatement
pour attaquer la tête le chêne d'options
sur ses seins à temps tout le monde dit
de me mettre la partie 4
gâtés pour dire allez voir les porter à
temps j'ai envie de voir tous les
échiquiers
cette année pour oui il nous revient de
voir
par rapporte 40 secondes en chirurgie 5
août
à partie 4 à ce que ses cris partie
3o la catastrophe ouais c'est terrible
alors que nous on vend c'est juste à
regarder des échecs à la hâte en
nombre important
[Musique]
on n'a pas les mêmes les mêmes centres
d'intérêts c'est terrible
marquis les parties sont passionnantes
en fait mais bon beaucoup moins
important mais attends je vais essayer
de régler les problèmes de micros une
bonne fois pour toutes
parce que c'est vrai que j'ai
l'impression contentant pas forcément
super bien et moi non plus
non je vais te passer le micro casque
non maison mais j'essaie de parler fort
explique comme ça après six rapports
horizontal vertical machin je vais pas
dire ça va tu as toute la journée en
raison des machins
peu importe mais là je vais faire
d'effort par les plus fragiles j'irai
quoi
vas-y franco vraiment creek enfin on
voit quoi on voit des décibels c'est
dans un concert fab
qu'on sorte que le play est complètement
ouais donc ce parti c'est quoi ces
nantis bas-rhinoise dons pour aider à 0
ouais donc attend ça c'est rapporte
nakamura
donc de 4/5 traquer ces six ou v5 qui
avale est ce un vrai fossé 50e'
berlinoise puis on prend le classique
fou j'ai cinq à six fois h4 g5 fou j'ai
trois fois 6 dames et deux qui a aidé
cette des 4 ok bon je sais pas trop qui
dit mieux quoi dire c'est une pulsion
assez classique après des cats est
normal d'essayer de faire une rupture
avec les blancs dans ce genre de
structure
pour attaquer le centre
a priori vaut mieux pas faire un pion
prendre quatre
bon bah alors dit
qu'à ça à l'air d'être une prépa nakai
aurès 1h56 mai mais en fait sur des
quatre oui je pense que prendrait un peu
plus peut-être juste comme f6 tue plein
de ton de 5,7 à moussa tu fais convoque
le cas et 17 aux pires rapatriera en
fuite g6 il va faire ça va être attaqué
donc
j'attends plus à elle six personnes
pour le moment il se passe rien vin il
se passe rien c'est l'ouverture il ya
personne a pris davantage où on va voir
comment n'a qu'à s'en sort qui double
les noirs un hikaru et donc duda
radjabov c'est la partie qu'on n'a pas
encore vu partie importante un pur duda
parce que radjabov bas ça devient la
cible du tournoi finalement web on
s'attendait dès le début un crac la
bouffonnerie souffre on l'a vu en
norvège les peines du monde et donc on
se dit est ce que c'est juste parce
qu'ils montrent pas ces ouvertures ou
quoi mais bon normalement tu vas tu
aimes pas autant souffrir des voies non
c'est juste qu'il un ton en dessous ces
temps ci et donc oui donc c'est une
cible et donc même ouverture sauf qu'il
n'a pas fait faux procès 6 mai est parti
aujourd'hui rouge et 5h si ce recul des
6 et cavalli et trois coups de
développement pourquoi pas bise à la
casse des cinq à nouveau à sion précise
n'est pas
vertueux après qu'elle ait des 5
normalement les noirs entoure toujours
g5 en poche pour les vitale pour éviter
le clouage way
et des cinq doit pas être une menace
immédiate immédiate
donc ok à voir avec les normes va nous
faire g5 direct soit dit un peu comme
n'a qu'à la partie précédente est ce
qu'il va nous faire un développement de
fou g4
sûrement les options mais c'est une
partie qui joue c'est pas une position
qui a été jouée des millions de fois et
donc papa de la part de l'adam n'est
directement à table sur un terrain où ça
joue sans réciter spécialement les
prépas quoi
on retourne sur
nepogodov
héros bien il a fait froid bien ou qui
n'est pas parti sur lequel j'ai 3 et
donc à 4 passe pour être le cas l'ancien
a priori
j'ai envie de voir
j'ai envie de voir la réaction de nez
pour 1,4 tempo est ce qu'il est bien le
frérot là je crois qu'il ya des cinq qui
part pour les noirs d'après les parties
aux correspondances que j'ai pu voir
moi ce que je pense ici c'est que né
peau connaissant sa gestion des
candidats s'y connaît pas bien il va pas
être mécontent de faire une petit nul
mais le truc c'est que la position est
assez sauvage et on connaît pas le degré
de dangerosité de la préparation du
joueur français qui jusque là est assez
qu'à roanne est ce que dans les
ouvertures je le trouve face à la
quatrième fois qui nous sort une idée
intéressante en quatre parties quand
même de son parti et qu'il a l'air de
connaître parfaitement une nouvelle
analyse l'ifop à 64
enfin je veux dire c'est sûrement sa
ligne principale pour le tendre parce
que si f3c le cours du moment côté blanc
car on allait jouer une épaule a joué là
ça c'est la ligne principale qui l'a
jugée contre vous c'est en homme
principal contre 4 c'est sûr tu n'es
très très bien quoi
et il envoie le d5 tempo et surtout il
affiche exactement la même confiance que
lors des trois premières rondes c'est à
dire qu'il est tranquille sur sa chaise
ça s'est vu en totale détente ils jouent
tous tempo ça si c'est une autre qualité
quand t'y connais en fait il jouit perd
pas de temps et ne bluffe pas dire dont
je connais pas wells on a vu d'autres
joueurs qui perdait 5 10 15 minutes et
au final
ben on voit dans ces partis le temps est
important à la fin alireza lui perd pas
tant il envoie ses prépas y connaît tous
par coeur et j'ai l'impression qu'il a
une mémoire d'éléphant ah ouais c'est
sûr en fait parce que déjà il beaucoup
de choses pour son âge
n'importe qui en fait mais il peut te
faire duo 4,5 avec les noirs il peut te
faire du 4 c 5 il a fait ça car au
cannet clément iphone 4 fait des quatre
îles le fait pas sans les connaître en
faisant des petites lignes en voie
principale
impressionnant et donc l'idée des 5e
décès de m ensuite le client décide
ce qu'il veut des buts qui faisait rien
hop le ramène pas 1 point de moins mais
est attaquée f5 tu veux conduire en 24
you pas mal de partout et blanc cf6 je
les prends
je comprends tu reprends ton truc j'ai
pas de quoi enfin et voit ses shows quoi
mais en fait évidemment quand avec les
blancs tu connais pas et que des noirs
tu as tout analysé bat un bel avantage
côté noir ou moins en pratique dire
objectivement ça doit avaler pour les
blanches basse et j'en suis persuadé ça
me paraît futile mais non mais ils la
ferment bien plus tôt quand ils vous
critiquer les trois dont déjà c'est une
première concession elle mourra bien
cette vallée mais le truc c'est que oui
tu joues contre alors dit en fait
m haies mais en plus la dangerosité de
d'alireza pour pour ses adversaires
c'est que même quand tu essayes de jouer
un coût qui n'est pas le principal tu
diras tient ce jour en avait un qui
avait trois principales mais en fait je
connais là aussi par cape times il me
fait je me demande si potentiellement
cet homme ne peut pas mettre au dessus
en prépa que caruana alors pas
maintenant un pas ici un journée est un
jour dans sa vie de femme j'ai
l'impression que c'est eux
enfin tu vois pas qu'est ce qu'il a
envie rhin guiry ou un cajon en tout cas
sur ses quatre premières parties des
candidats rien il est surprenant dans
les ouvertures il peut tout jouer je
sais pas si tu vas te faire et à chaque
fois ils te réussit il te récipient
mêmes qu'en rapporte lui a joué à une
surprise avec le dame prend des quatre
là encore il connaît la ville avait
encore jusqu'à cinq tours à 6 il a tous
les jours très loin et que tu joues
principal pas principal enfin c'est
assez c'est assez costaud quand même
mdr il est dans le match dans les deux
premières parties quand même alors déjà
use des aides enfin je suis d'accord
avec toi il est normal mais c'est pas
dans l'ouverture donc c'est il est dans
le match après mais dont on parle d
ouverture ici et il a l'air vraiment
vraiment très très affûté il est
confiant il joue toujours vite
hein c'est après qu'il n'a peut-être pas
été ultra précis je sais pas contrat de
la poste intéressant ce qui faisait 150
localités tout ça
rentre de contrat portera il n'a pas
trop bien je la finale il faut dire est
qu'on n'a qu'à et la revue la pression
un haka très bien défendu quand même
faut dire mais un peu de réussite côté
draka quand même
non mais oui oui très bien préparés
alors on va rajouter les points mais
c'est vrai que là les pendules on veut
guère
valera ajouté il n'y a pas de souci on
va en profiter pour voir la caméra de
nos amis
doute à elie radjabov
et on va aller jeter un oeil
à les rejeter mais je suis en train de
les récupérer par extraordinaire c'est
que la partie de référence là dessus
parti de tenir à une tchèque les blancs
forcément une grosse prépa à 2100
s'il réussit daniel féau contre 1 2106
qu'il était vraiment très bien préparé
mais ce qu'il a payé
c'est la question qu'on se pose
les lacunes qu'il en finale ne se
résoudraient sûrement pas avant des
années 1 et contre peut-être déjà mais
qu'importe pat ans a rien à faire
elysium un je ne sais pas
comment ça va en fait ça wily final
c'est pas
dur de faire des pronostics
on sait pas en fait
non mais après qu'il eut face au monde
qui lui file pardon au moins six mois ça
s'est su enfin il va pas régler en une
semaine
j'ai appris toutes les finales il n'y a
pas la salle des temps comme dans dragon
ball z mais après peut-être que six mois
de travail intensif ça suffit peut-être
un an ça suffit peut-être juste qu'il
peut pas parce que il est
intellectuellement il peut pas
il peut pas y arriver on ne sait pas en
fait
quel serait le meilleur premier table
pour des 3 et magnus peut-être caruana
un finalement
déjà c'est magnus ne joue pas
tout le monde saphir ou quoi
je dis ça parce que max a dit que
je n'ai pas envie de nouveaux matches
champion du monde sauf si c'est ali reza
coupe d'europe je me rappelle une
victoire de sa part sur une finale nul
contre un top 10 est pas un moche non
plus en finale alors on a déjà expliqué
avec la déjà savoir que les finales où
on est mieux essalouh on a un peu moins
bien ou c'est égal ce sont deux choses
assez différentes
et deuxièmement je rappelle quand même
que mamediarov dans cette partie avait
forcé le lien oui pas dans la finale
mais avant et
c'est pas tout à fait une partie
habituel après c'est vrai qu'il avait
bien géré sa finale avec avantage
cependant quand on pense à la finale
qu'il a bien joué on en cite une mais
celle qu'il a mal joué on peut en citer
une ribambelle notamment celles qu'on
oublie souvent c'est celle contre mayer
oui il a fini par gagner parce que mayer
a gaffé mais en réalité il a laissé
échapper le gain avant nommer la pierre
qu'on va se tester contre car
l'opposition au mca deux ans déjà rimer
oui oui
c'est la pire de tout
faire pour venir la partie là là ça
passe on a pardonné pour qui a pas perdu
de temps à faire reprendre
parce qu'elle est née en d6 le problème
des salaires il fait ici je dirais que
c'est plutôt un bon coup j'étais pas à
quel point c'est meilleur que l'autre
mais ça a l'air intéressant
et en groban époque il va toujours calé
j'ai 3 il va venir par le roi noir qui
sera quand même affaiblie
et on voit un réseau qui commence à
réfléchir donc
pas longtemps
mais
c'est s'attendait plus à le prendre et
je pense
la théorie de quel côté ya plus deux
parties s'étaient eux prend déclarant
c'est que trois parties
il boit un peu d'eau ancien joueur de
poker on te dis que ça traduit une
inquiétude
après peut-être qu'il ajuste soif aussi
hélas alors dit jeudi qu'il avalise g3
ses cervicales et g3
relativement logique tg3 jeudi
il a repris ses nouveautés
est ce que tu penses qui connaît où il
est en totale impro
je pense qu'il improvise
est ce qu'on peut faire un peu
tournicoter ça tournicote côté turbines
il me 0 0 mais c'est normal ça leur
donne un bon c'est quand même bon signe
enfin faire ça veut déjà dire que il
réfute pas
choquer enfin l'argent qui n'est en
impro et je trouve qu'il joue vite
ces dépôts quoi oui mais jersey sawa
fischer beaucoup au kg 3 par rapport à
rien talent oratoire de prendre le 6
août à droite chargé prend faire
corriger 3g problème à beaucoup de prise
de décision possible donc même s'il a
réfléchi sur ses standards sauf que vu
la complexité de la position eu tous
même jouer vite alors après il faut
quand même dire qu'il ya un phénomène on
en discute avec vlad et autres jours
c'est que parfois si tu sais que tu
comprendras pas
surtout quand tu es dans l'après pas
encore si tu sais que tu comprendras pas
faut mieux envoyer un truc un peu vite
parce que - le gars en face c'est pas si
tu connais tu connais pas et toi de
toute façon tu aurais jamais réussi à
savoir s'il valait mieux faire gfk
valley g3 ont en fait tu peux partir du
principe
je comprendrais jamais vas-y je joue
maintenant à toi de
toi te démerder peut-être je connais tu
es je connais pas je ne sais pas non
mais c'est en vrai il ya une logique en
fait aussi un joueur de poker est un jeu
vocal aussi mais moi j'ai des limites
que de côtoient leurs tubes wattrelos je
te fais des progrès était inquiet par
ailleurs je lui tends inquiétudes moi je
ne vois aucune aucunement vous regarde
bourg-madame
bien je suis dans la salle où il fait
vraiment très chaud pour suer pour
pouvoir un petit peu boire sinon c'est
jamais soif
ne suis pas inquiet je ne me touche pas
le visage aille pas je ne trahis aucun
aucun geste
donc là
[Musique]
et en vrai j'ai envie de dire d'un côté
on peut se dire on n'a plus envie de
prendre du cavalier 2d pour aller avec
l'otan f6 d'un autre côté on peut dire
je veux plutôt prendre de ce cavalier
pour être la tour en huit on peut aussi
dire non je prends du fou je couvre les
cases noires chaque fois sa logique
chacun a sa logique
ça s'annonce être une belle partie ouais
je suis d'accord avec ce qui est écrit
dans le chat ça s'annonce être un combat
acharné
enfin bon site de deir ezzor sont chaque
jour assez intéressante photo moi je
trouve que c'est le joueur avec caruana
le plus intéressant à suivre au niveau
personnellement
parce que toutes les parties sont
dynamiques et intéressante passe d'être
changées de venir en costume pas je
crois
il ya eu ce qu'on ne peut appeler la lie
à kate n'a qu'à gate keepers gates
n'a carey qui a été critiqué parce qu'il
a faim pas critiquer il a une urne mail
en de la fidh remontrances une
remontrance suis tu n'es pas en costume
donc c'est un peu suez côtes américains
il ya d'autres personnes qui sont
montées au créneau en disant ouais
comment vous pouvez que la chica rousset
celui qui fait le plus pour les échecs
nanani nanana
à raison ou à tort mais en tout cas ça
fait parler ça fait cool et j'ai pas
envie de dire beaucoup de manques parce
que hors du milieu des échecs personne
n'a absolument rien à [ __ ] mais dans
le microscopique milieu des échecs ça un
petit peu par l'hôte et ses amis de
screen sur le
tarif il est ici a fait beaucoup pour
les échecs du coup il aurait le droit de
mettre des shorts alors est ce que moi
je peux et dans quel but
alors et pour le coup en plus c'était
pas si mal habillé
juste un peu casual et une chemise bleue
ait une chemise bleue donc la bombe
aussi quoi en fait un jeu le votre
commentaire je suis pas sûr je vais me
prendre une remontrance orange
s'était pas partie
mais
il ya des compensations et un gros
dynamisme pour les noirs après
voilà fin septembre les blancs ils sont
donnés un pion d'air
en échange d'une vers la colonne vers le
roi noir un défaut à six étrangers qui
vient il ya locales et g3 qui va bondir
tu as des casses pour entrer bas
notamment f5 a évidemment entraîné dans
l'esprit de tout reproche
donc voilà des pièces qui arrivent qui
convergent côté plon 6
être des quatre on n'a pas le temps il
ya puis on prend 1,7 oui il faut le
prendre ce pion en plus il est chiant je
veux dire enfin je vis ici contrôler la
casse g7 qui pourrait être un tremplin
pour notre pièce notamment une dame ou
quoi donc les limites fait juste plaisir
quoi qu'il en soit
pourquoi alors venu dans le foot pro f 6
e +2 mince à paraître en fin de tous les
coups c'est celui journellement à le
regarder mais a déjà
passé si mauvais par rapport aux autres
je n'ai pas tellement envie de sport et
du cabillaud
[Musique]
8,8
après ça dépend ouais ça dépend vraiment
si tu as envie de rebondir en d6 ou pas
c'est vraiment faim stratégiquement en
fait c'est rien à dire alors de vlad de
trouverez une raison il te dis oui mais
qu'ils en fait c'est très logique ici
mais en réalité là c'est bien parce que
c'est bien
plus rien puisque les deux ovales
d'après les ordis après fou prend c'est
quoi on pourrait un peu avec la petite
turbine est
g37 et j'entends
on a souffrance et 4 le pion dès que
déjà c'est avec les qualités défendre
elle un autre ira moins cette menace il
faut prendre fin
en revanche pas calais ou assez
logiquement à changer
elles sont des
4,6
g73 se faire échanger attaquer
on n'était pas obligé de prendre dans le
sens où le fouetter
5 même direct alors ça c'est dangereux
pour le n 1 alors après je vois pas je
vois pas bon à part des ventes du coup
mais pourquoi sur qui a veillé prendra
pas des scénarios si mineur genre kg 3
ok dit ce que je voulais faire 6 on va
dire c'est la qualité mais moi je suis
fou prend disons parce que pascal le
coup que ouais t'as envie de regarder la
maison pillon
ça c'est bien à trois puisque tu as tu
dis quasiment
voilà ça illustre bien l'idée en fait
genre dame prend b4 qui a et b 5 à ses
variantes de redire
quatre
variantes d'ordi taïwan - la tête une
tour une tour de moins mais jean rouger
cet imparable un rock plus
haut c'est une vente et on aurait pu
inquiet premiers de pro b 5 mais oui en
gros tu me fous g7 et
les ai découvertes et vous juste être
plus à l'aise si je
devais titre
donc du coup si on part du principe on
va un peu résumé que l'on veut sacrifier
la qualité et qu'on veut les cases
noires c'est plus logique de prendre
deux des
noms d'autres
cavaliers apprend faut acheter son
peuple de faire à peu près les mêmes
trucs de rachid ben
ouais mais à lui tu vas aller vers 5,5
fois par mois je vais bien des six n'ont
fait toi et c5 c'est pas mal aussi
en fait on sait pas non mais sûrement
fait de coûts doivent se voir trop fins
votre frère analysés pour au revoir mais
disons le redis les considère à peu près
pareil pour l'instant et
on
voit
alors il a joué il ya eu qu'un valet
déprend et cavaliers g iii auxquelles
s'attend à quoi qui va l'aider si ce nom
vous voyez des six c'est ce qu'ont à
regarder juste avant je crois ouais
donc invalidée ici ce pour jaillir après
on pourrait aussi je vois que l'ordi à
propose sirois je suis tu sais que tu
peux aussi anticiper farewell fuite et
garder toutes les options
parce que tu auras besoin de le faire
moi je suis tombé tous les cas quand il
en soit jamais un jour je suis un peu
l'équivalent du roi bien des blancs très
souvent ayral et au moins tu te garde
dames c'est celle qui a aidé six tours
c8 vous pourrez enfin j'en sais rien
tous les coups rappelez il faut regarder
roi suite france et 4 quand même et
prend ses katas me prends des 8 parce
que ce serait le seul cas de figure où
trois jeunes pousses et 50
quel sens n'a pas peut-être pas très
envie j'aime pas à ses pions surtout
c'est pas pour le style de fillon où on
a décrit final c'est moi son truc
après je sais pas celle là pour être mal
mais ça déplorable faible effectivement
mannequins et des six appareils chez moi
tu contrôles f5 tu tapes ici
il faut acheter soit 8 et vous pensez qu
attaquer les français quatre fois çi
sera ensuite après faut peut-être pas la
bouffe et ce tour oui oui mais ça c'est
encore un là c'est encore une autre
réflexion mais bondam g5 ton g8
c'est complexe
ça on l'avait pas c'est vrai qu'on avait
le chemin long des 7
et donc fc sète alors des foreuses 5 et
défense écarte enfin défend enlève la
dame de la mauvaise case ih la fois ici
pour la qualité je crois que fait
bon vivre et de garder une fois ci
s'attaque
donc dams et c'est peut-être camani f5
du coup on profite du cavalier pas venu
en d6 et on va crever le fouet cette
roue à la suite qu'ils allaient prendre
un set on est content on a gagné un
tempo
pas de quoi la main reprennent du full
donc j'ai bien j'imagine
j'ai pas trop les noirs dont j'aime pas
les noirs non plus parce que
le roi est très bien défendu et qui les
défend la casa 2 qui est le point
culminant de la tacc si tu joues un
joueur et k3 l'écrasement tu les as
jamais parce que c'est les blancs qui
ont le fou de cases noires et le roi
noir le roi des noirs paris faible après
vente hamas de pion central et les
blancs ont plus de pions pour faire des
dégâts sur la patine braques ou tu peux
tu as tu peux faire un mur mèche
vu comme ça je me sentirais pas méga la
zac après je rappelle que dans la
dernière partie ultra compliqué que né
pourra jouer contre firoud déjà c'était
à bucarest pour le grand duché ce tour
est dans une position à peu près
similaire veut pas similaires dans le
style une position très dynamique et
très déséquilibré comme on a là c'est le
joueur russe qui avait surclassé le
français
donc je peux comprendre qu ali reza que
né peau accepte le combat le combat mais
ça veut dire que les peaux ici il
considère qui peut prendre le large dans
les candidats c'est une partie qu'il a
ciblé pour gagner en fait
il est en gestion ici non mais n'est pas
je crois qu'en fait justice
il veut saisir des opportunités si elles
se présentent il va pas aller suicide
est la plus refuser mais toute façon les
candidats en fait c'est un tournoi où
t'es pas l'apporter points elo est là
pour gagner le tournoi il ya que c'est
intéressant après que fit dernier ou en
fait quelque part c'est pareil et donc
chaque demi point qu'on ne faut pas
avoir balles perdues
faut pas cacher les munitions et donc
je dis pas ça avant la partie tu te dis
pas à moi super apparemment ceux des
blancs contre ali reza mais si jamais la
participerait t40 a peut-être une chance
pas senti
le choix pratique donné peau d'un voyage
si c'est qu'un valet g3 rapidement été
excellent et je pense parce que
finalement il est sorti de la prépa
d'alireza il n'a pas joué de mauvais
coups non pas de ça va ça va et il n'a
pas perdu de temps donc et ça c'est une
des grandes forces de dépôt ils
paniquent pas en fait
il n'a absolument rien à [ __ ] en fait
non mais c'est un point fort parce qu'il
trouve des bons coups il renverse la
pression c'est lui qui devait être sous
pression
il a renversé la pression en deux temps
trois mouvements et c'est pas pour rien
qu'il a gagné les candidats qu'il a été
champion de russie en 2020 et et que
c'est un joueur du premier plan alors
évidemment il a perdu le match contre
magnus et le score est lourd et même un
petit peu humiliant en quelque sorte les
normes à l'aube du match normal au vu du
match mais c'est peut-être un petit peu
en trompe l'oeil sur ceux qui
connaissent pas la carrière de yann qui
a une carrière à haut niveau depuis
depuis plus d'une dizaine d'années et
qui a réellement beaucoup progressé
depuis depuis le lac assure qu vide on
qui a beaucoup travaillé et est qui qui
revient en force j'ai envie de dire
logiquement
wen ont valu son cher son défaut
principal c'est un peu de tilter ça se
passe mal ça quand tu perds repère les
vitres et ça s'enchaîne mais quand il
est en confiance quand il joue bien il
joue bien je voudrais bien
là en fait lui sa chance à chercher les
gagner la première ronde avec les noirs
et forcément ça ne m'est bien dans le
tournoi confiant sûr de lui et du coup
oui oui il faudra compter sur lui
la première partie du match mais poker
scène était impressionnante
ares s'est toujours et dans la partie 6
après est ce qu'il y a vraiment cru
aussi un
yann peut-être qu'il n'y a jamais
vraiment cru à sa chance ouais bah je
sais pas un vrai c'est dommage de ne pas
y croire ça c'est peut-être une chance
une fois dans sa vie bah oui mais
carlson il est plus fort tout le monde
en fait comme ça donc forcément tu es
pas favoris mais t'as pas zéro chance
non plus énormément
sur si je joue dix fois le match tu vas
pas gagné souvent
ou pas non mais tu peux si le 15 les
malins les
pilotes fans gays
mais aussi car c'est notre influx comme
idée qui peut pas venir à jouer moi
c'est ya des trucs dans le règne en fait
c'est comme roue de contreras fin en
fait c'est un peu ça ouais en vrai c'est
un peu ça
le problème c'est que je voudrais avec
plus fort toi
si tu regarde quelqu'un de plus fort et
il suit pas de battre une partie un
match c'est comme d'hab à lui prendre un
set sur terre battue c'est déjà dur leur
prendre trois
le problème
c'est dur
ça réfléchissait avec un quota alireza
près de façon on n'a pas le choix ici
hein tu dois réfléchir mais c'est le
genre de position ou ali reza est très à
l'aise ça va être un énorme combat là
c'est un combat de rue entre les deux
hommes ils sont tous les deux sur leurs
points forts et ils sont tous les deux
top 5 mondial dans la catégorie position
bordélique mais très avec bon car la
scène quand même dans tous les cas parce
que carl scène même si ce n'est pas sa
spécialité il surclasse tellement tout
le monde qu'il est forcément bon lvl
évidemment c'est un nom qui te vient
tout de suite en tête ali reza dépôt est
peut-être un peu de naka caruana dans le
règne mais ouanna cas sûrement car
renault
tient c'est pas tellement le bordel
qu'il aime c'est calculé loin précis
méticuleux quoi mais très profond
est-ce qu'on mettrait un ding irène il
est capable dé quoi mais un ding d'irène
bond d'environ 18 est ce que tous bien
quand même faudrait
alors d'où peuvent clairement pas un il
est à deux trois catégories en dessous
aronian c'est plus qu'un média rohff ça
a eu été le cas mais non ici me est
maintenant en dessous de ces joueurs là
mais ouais c'est des joueurs qui sont
ici on pourrait dire kasparov mais
pourrait dire fischer
mort fi en option reprenait tous les
tous les grands joueurs de l'histoire on
pourrait citer beaucoup de noms mais on
parle du haut niveau actuel forcément tu
mettrais alireza nepomniachi dans le top
le quinté peut-être pas dans l'ordre
mais
les cars nissan en fait il évite ce
genre de combat oui mais il en est
capable bah oui dit capable de tout mais
c'est pas trop de partir tu as tout ce
qui se passe ce à quoi un an justement
il choisit bien pour éviter vérité que
ça arrive parce qu on est bon on disait
pour le match voix qui crée ce genre
scénario est jamais arrivé c'est plus
démarche a laissé des catalanes ont
choisi
baron fou peut-être aussi
il faut après généralement le mais pas
parce qu'il est hors catégorie
très belle réaction des points je me
répète mais je suis assez impressionné
par ce qu'il vient de faire yann c'est
vraiment pas facile qui vient réaliser
réussir à voir la
la la la lucidité de répondre rapidement
par un genre de petit con tre bluff
l'invité bien vite et bien c'est très
très très bien joué c'est vraiment c'est
là qu'on voit vraiment le plus haut
niveau de l'exigence de ces hommes et
qui sont capables de faire des choses
que le commun des mortels ne peut pas
avec deux mois en tant qu'adversaire ça
m'énerve qu'on fasse ça
moi j'ai envie que le mec réfléchissent
quoi ta ta ta cinq candidats passent du
temps et non pas fictif dans ta gueule
libye plus pour sa banque ou quoi ça
vient vite à coups de mer le samba comme
moi je suis fin quand je jouais a
évidemment à mon petit niveau de coin
mais
j'aimais bien ce genre de position
j'étais très heureux
mais j'avais parfois à ma grande époque
surclassé md ou mec à 25 50 26 dans ses
calculs la pour après perdre en finale
j'étais très mauvais en finale alors que
j'étais mieux traverser maintenant et
j'ai traversé maintenant c'est pour
faire un petit parallèle et pour dire
que c'est pas parce que tu débutes comme
ali reza comme un énorme joueur
d'attaqué et moyens au final que tu
changes pas complètement de style et je
les pensées pour comparer à lire et
c'est un joueur comme murray talhouët
ses preuves et qui naît l'idée était un
énorme joueur d'attaqué on connaît tous
pour ces partis flamboyante et qui est
devenu un excellent joueur de finale par
la suite qui après à deux fois fait un
énorme strict sans défaites pointe de 90
partis ou sont dit enfin je conviens
mais deux fois il a fait une première
série ou un jour il a perdu une partie
un an ou deux plus tard il est reparti
il a refait le truc
est pas content des plots au tournoi de
l'époque ont fait meilleure dans les
années milieu des années 70 soit
étiqueté conférence de presse après ou
avant lé match en surtemps majeur alors
j'ai vu des petites interviews d'après
match mais rien de flamboyant en termes
d'intérêt en ce qui concerne la
conférence de presse d'avant tournoi
elle a eu lieu mais le truc c'est que
les joueurs n'étaient pas obligés d'y
participer et il n'y a qu'un seul joueur
qui est venu participer c'est caruana
très professionnel mais les autres
joueurs ne sont simplement pas venu et
là encore malheureusement si on souhaite
populariser notre sport
il va falloir que les joueurs apprennent
eux aussi à être disponibles pour les
médias même si on nettoie difficile je
vois même des stars du niveau de nadal à
cristiano ronaldo sont en capacité de
donner des conférences de presse
dans les moments les plus importants
c'est vrai qu'aux échecs ce serait bien
que les joueurs
sachent s'exprimer
oui non cessionnaire membres est je
pense que la faute juste pas là c'est le
choix on est la conférence de presse et
puis voilà
mais il faudra aussi leur apprendre à
parler aussi plus globalement puisqu'on
m'a beaucoup il s'exprime moins bien que
des joueurs de foot
eh bah après quand on ne parle pas oui
messieurs non mais oui c'est dommage
mais non mais j'arrive de foot mais que
ça pas parler de base non plus j'imagine
mais juste ils ont des des coaches qui
leur apprennent à 3 communications
communication je me rappelle pour ceux
qui ont une pour ceux qui ont suivi le
poker ou dans le milieu des années 2000
il ya un joueur qui s'appelait dur oui
des rmr dur quand tu vois ses première
conférence de presse c'est hallucinant
il ne sait pas
enchaîner deux mots des gens réellement
c'est absolument catastrophique il ne
s'est juste pas parler tu as
l'impression d'un fou furieux qui sort
d'une cave mais réellement et tu le vois
un an après il a évidemment étaient
coachés par les plus grandes plateformes
de poker qui ont décidé de le mettre en
avant parce qu'il avait gagné des sommes
incroyables et il s'exprime est
extrêmement bien et en fait il avait
même pris des faire un truc fantastique
il avait même pris un coach en boîte de
nuit pour à lui apprendre à draguer des
meufs relevé des trésors il y avait
plein d'argent bah il a vraiment
travaillé là dessus donc oui oui au jard
à coacher le gars fait j'ai lu dans
l'atteinte du guépard et udp disturb
mille balles et il va avec tout en boîte
et où il t'apprend à bientôt alors ces
discussions a bien danser à we say it
champêtre avec ses prendrait six hausses
avec hyper barak lâché un super beau
gosse oui tu apprends un peu et de faire
le sport et tout est vraiment quand tu
revois ce dur genre un an ou deux ans
après personne web est il très à l'aise
en conférence de presse il a et donc pas
être ça s'apprend sais c'est pas
forcément naturel regardez au foot ou au
tennis ou quoi qu'on en dise qui
s'apprend c'est pas possible qu'ils
soient tous bon en fait alors que quand
tu les vois aujourd'hui ils sont tous
bons
bien c'était tom dwan la légende doit
avoir regardé ses première conférence de
presse
c'est assez terrible lorsque après ses
deux ministres
ont soif de victoires des stades allez
allez elle tournait le sai
leur fabrique a fléchi c'est donc et à
cinq de ses cinq jeux c'est b6 est
debout
on va regarder un bon voyage à cliquer à
fond on peut échanger son mauvais four
on peut très égal en fait plus agréable
quand même parce que colonnes cm tiens
ça me fait penser à la partie musique
rpp transfère nausicaa sauf que là bas
pas assez t'as pas tout à fait les mêmes
ingrédients mais ouais un peu
plein de ça
mais c'était une bien meilleure version
petrossian on doit pas regarder souvent
les conférences de presse de foot ils
sont très bons en laisse ou non mais je
parle des mails en fait d'étape toi je
parle paribas 2,5 hors dia mondiale et
puis ils vont quand tu prends le mec
juste avant la mi temps essoufflé qui
doit rentrer au vestiaire et que je te
dira oui on est mené au score on va tout
faire pour revenir dès mi temps allait
va rien dire d'intéressant mais cessons
d conférence d'avant match où là il
vienne où il ya tous les sponsors il ya
la conférence de presse du coach et d'un
joueur qui veulent bon bah là ça va
c'est un peu plus intéressant même si
souvent en fait ils sont 5èmes cadre et
pour pas trop de gardes eurent du mal ou
ouais mais ça ça passe et un somme rezaï
comme et même moi qui regarde beaucoup
de rugby les conférences à la mi temps
fin de l'année mais qu'ils s'envoyaient
40 minutes on y arrive c'est
assez bien fait en fait
mes parents bloqués au tennis angels
assez intéressant ouais et aussi un
autre truc pour les échecs tant que j'y
suis aussi qu'il parle d'autre chose que
je devais rentrer des chèques
non mais c'est vrai que souvent les
conférences de presse c'est oui j'ai
raté que je pouvais faire se déprend
détroit je comprends pas c'est après 25
à 3 à 5 b 4 il y avait tous ces
intermédiaires mais ça en fait le public
on s'en fout en fait vous jure j'ai raté
s'agira t il n'y a pas de parce que
machin est juste plus parler des
émotions du ressenti et pouvoir faire
des interviews compréhensibles par des
gens qui ne jouent pas trop aux échecs
est pas pareil de fans confiance tu as
une analyse en fait non mais ces deux
trucs différents corps et c'est ça qu'on
confond souvent dans les échecs
en ce qui concerne la partie ii rapporte
contre nakamura ça va ça trouve un
vantail c'est quand même un peu mieux au
blanc mais ça va probablement aller perd
1,11 cette finale évidemment donc il ya
toujours cette histoire de majorité 4
contre 3 allée droit donc voilà
cela dit pour l'instant c'est bien
bloquer tous passés avec les blancs le
roi des dracs plus actifs et dangereux 7
par rapport au roi julien qui a rockets
la perte de temps à revenir il va
revenir un jour mais voilà
c'est pas trop inquiétant pour naka il a
encore beaucoup beaucoup de temps à la
pandémie a pris sur dante ressenti
émotions ça même des billets à tes
adversaires alors oui un petit peu mais
bon au bout d'un moment
tu prends cinq cent mille euros un
million par an fin oui mais c'était
oublier mais comme au tennis on demande
qu'est ce que vous en pensez machin il
te dit pas j'ai bien dis que tu es mon
coup droit et j'ai vu thi j'ai vu ça oui
il ya ce point à 30a j'ai fait ça a
failli te raconte pas tous les points
quoi il te dit une conférence de presse
moi qui m'avait marqué de djokovic après
un match contre nadal
en atp 1000 ou un truc comme ça et il
avait dit oui maintenant j'ai réussi à
bien travailler mon revers croisé pour
le défoncer sur son coup droit je vais
le battre au prochain prochain grand
ancien dont j'ai compris comment battre
nadal et j'avais laissé j'ai vu ça je
sais juste ok et j'avais regardé leurs
matchs suivants qui étaient en grand
chelem et il avait fait ça tout le match
et on regarde je te croise sur son
revers et je t'attaque sur son coup
droit et c'est intéressant parce qu'on
était carrément dit son plan de jeu 1
mais vous devez savoir c'est un bluff
aussillon et du coup nadal il avait dû
probablement réglé le truc mais en fait
c'est hyper intéressant de dire ça j'ai
réfuté par les gens regardent je taille
la prochaine salut j'ai mis mes chers
par là qu'ils disent des choses vraiment
intéressantes parfois
bon peu importe
et puis c'est leur métier c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont très bien payés aux syriens
qui au bout d'un moment ça fait partie
ça fait partie du jeu on peut importe à
et du coup il nous reste et georgia
contre duda alors nous je t'avoue qu'on
doit être plus tôt pour timour un ici
clairement c'est dans notre intérêt que
tu sais pas qui laisse pas des punto 1
et ouais écoute ça je voulais faire
5 6 3
6 est-ce que vous rendrez cinquième coup
t'as pas le temps de prendre là parce
que c'est sûr échec oui
quand j'ai vite être kébé 6 ab fois ci
c'est ce qu'il ya du jeu
ces people ça c'est sûr
seulement même rush limbaugh
ça me rappelle une fois morte à s'il
avait fait un sacrifice comme ça contre
un gendre être assez fort et
le camp et trouve à suivre cette équipe
au ton truc bon je vous rappelle
l'urssaf que les faits un court tu sais
bien tu as caché élèves qui étaient
genre 70e mondiale je vous dis oui bon
ben c'est pipeau mais j'ai quand même
gagner enfin que quand même étonné j'ai
quand même te faire un bond à tanger
vite bon bah oui enfin c'est pipeau mais
un bon enfin j'en absolument je sais pas
si ces médias l'ordi aime bien les noirs
d'être courageux n'étaient pas précis
mais en tout cas sans caillou cette
façon que le réflexe est de faire ce
premier 6 si tu veux faire j'ai prendre
je vais prendre 17 g faire cavaler h
théâtre je sais pas je suis quand même
pas clairement mieux ouais mais je vais
faire comment rang 4 5 enfin si tu peux
pas m'empêcher f5 donc les lâche 4 il va
regarder
ton g8 de kébé 6,2 me d'alger 3
f30
c'est n'a pas accès à 8,5 est en réalité
le cavalier recette est bien placé on se
perd pas trop on se lève à tirer de
cette vous mon info qu'on lâche var a
fait dans sa partie
ouest banalise non mais je voulais
elle est située en dire plus je te sens
vraiment mais je sais pas quoi dire en
fait ça dépend ce qu'il faut c'est
jouable ou pas si c'est pas un danger
pour les noirs qu elle s est très bien
il va revenir vers g6 ils échangent un
peu d'ethias il se replace et
concret il est dans sa partie initiale
en anglais ds
on a 400 kg
et l'habillage piste bleue
il admet lui l'arrêt la flamme est
peut-être avec la veste
la pompe
caruana ça réfléchit encore
et on va retourner sur le joueur
français à lire et zafy round jackie est
lancé dans une longue réflexion après
qu'un maillage étroit il est déjà à mon
avis un peu plus de 20 minutes un de
réflexion ici attention ne pas se mettre
trop mal autant sa gestion du temps a
été assez correcte jusque là même si
parfois il a réfléchi un petit peu trop
longtemps mais cette partie là elle est
différente il n'a pas le matelas
nécessaire
et il va falloir faire attention et
peut-être accéléré côté côté français
bon après
on va dire le bon côté que vous déjà
joué vingrau
donc on rit là encore 1h23 pour un coup
seulement donc là ses premiers coups ont
pas le prouver ses qualités au cavalier
seul problème ce type
là ses premiers qu'on va dire où il doit
vraiment réfléchir est très bon la pâte
faire du coup par coup si l'analyse
c'est en profondeur
complètement femmes
1h 1h30 si ce n'est pour lui il va
réussir à but c'est sa partie comme
d'hab il aura pas de pas de souci c'est
sur
ce qu'est g4 est possible pour éviter
fois le sismographe j'ai l'impression
que t'es pas
t'es pas placé pour le genre de coup
franc c4 a pas le temps de prendre deux
trois sinon t'es fou et donc tu dois
reprendre ses 4 et maintenant peut-être
dames 2 double attaque
fatale ça tu ne peux pas malheureusement
donc on est à l'heure de jeu fable c'est
le moment de faire notre petit point
résumé sur sur la partie d'alireza donc
on a une minute chrono mon fab pour
si on le veut on le fait ensemble
on se lance dans quoi allez on se lance
dans trente secondes on récupère nos
esprits
en condition
je répondrais que je trouve que dans
cette première phase n'est pas fait
preuve de solidité je trouve changée
depuis karl scène fut posée par les deux
comme il était avant car le sel en fait
car arsène a simplement est un intermède
pour le joueur
russe
donc le résumé express fab aller sa part
ian nepomniachi avec les blancs contre
ali reza firoud déjà il envoie e4 et
alireza qui répond c5 et nepomniachi qui
va jouer une sicilienne ouverte et
alireza qui va répondre par la nage
dorff on sait qu'il est capable de
l'envoyer mai
connaissez pas son idée en avant match
c'est quand même une petite surprise
surtout contre un spécialiste du genre
et une époque qui va jouer f3 le coup
qui semble fab à la mode dans ces
candidats comme car on avait joué on a
contraint mais sur quoi les rasages où
la grande ligne donc c'est un cataclysme
a dit et qui valait 3
3 en fait on va suivre une très grande
ligne dames d2 petit rock rock et qui
avait ip 17 et blanc voit g4 les noirs
ou arabes et 5 août chacun psg cinq
attaques lecavalier 6
mai 4 tacle qui règne en c3 les blancs
en live ce qu'était le même temps le 2
les noirs enlèvent leurs caves et 8
f4 pour l imposition à 5 ça attaque dans
tous les sens f5 et ici grosse surprise
de fil rouge à qui on joue le coup à 4
qui un peu comme b4 sur g5 contre
attaquer le kenyan b3 il va simplement
dépassé son français 4 grosse réflexion
enfin parler sans ramener peau qui fait
roi bien simplement comme ça sur un
cadre de cacher son client
cd5 en raison de la pression au centre
l'hyper le foot gaz noir et f6 cours
l'euro à terre en fait chacun joue à
fond son attaque sautée gf gf cavaliers
déprend église et g3 donc échanger tout
cas ce blanche permettre de venir vers
f5 et on en met la pression très
compliqué pour les deux joueurs peuvent
attaquer le roi adverse au combat mais
petit ruggieri sur une greffe tome 20
minutes et on attend son cou pour voir
la suite de la partie
c'est le petit résumé
c'était le petit résumé
n'est peau à l'air changé depuis qu'ils
consomment pas 3 litres de café par
partie ah bah ça je sais pas hein
ça je sais pas si les concerts ne voit
pas
sa petite bouteille d'eau mais je suis
un peu déçu c'est à d autres candidats
des fauteuils quoi
sinon ils n'ont pas donné le choix en
fait cette année dommage que j'aime bien
le grand fauteuil vert le petit fauteuil
de la petite chaise
c'est intéressant
au coccyx en arts martiaux tels droits
chaque rencontre un sabre contre un truc
l'annoncé que des nunchakus pour tout le
monde c'est dommage
trop de monde chaque coup en fait
lâche éric asselin et en plus elles
n'ont pas l'air enfin
mieux que quoi et en plus le choix des
photos de photos est différent on est
très bien
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête de
fioul calculant tout bêtement
non mais peut pas être en pm est en fait
parce que l'iseq savante va
et que nemo a pas joué une principale
donc il sait que c'est pas le coup a
priori numéro 1 des ordi pour qu
objectivement sa position va maintenant
c'est à lui de faire le boulot pour
trouver les bons coups sur l'échiquier
dans une position a compliqué un
évidement mais donc et pas en paix elle
a su style ans il fait son effort de
calcul quoi
il va prendre il va faire son choix mais
bon faut pas qu'ils traînent trop même
si talives un coup
1h18 ça suffit largement faut pas que ce
qu'ils avaient bien à un moment donné
contre radjabov sur trois coups genre 75
minutes
enfin faut pas qu'ils se qui se foutent
avec 25 minutes autant pour jouer les
deux prochains coups
parce que là ça pourrait être difficile
dans une position très compliqué ce
serait bien qu'ils jouent là dans les
dix minutes qui viennent on va dire ne
pas dépasser les 35 minutes de réflexion
parce que c'est pas un coût qui paraît
complètement décisif non plus et il y
aura beaucoup de bifurcation
bah
ouais je crois que c'est nanan ghz est
déjà sur plus d'un quart d'heure sur un
coup
pas forcément super bon signe après
[Musique]
générale 3 dire
c'est une qualité qu'on lui découvre la
paix pas elle a bonne mémoire donc ben
oui et non en fait ce que comme je
l'avais dit dans les tournois mineurs
entre guillemets c'est sûr qu'il n'avait
pas envoyé ses lignes principales et il
est quand même globalement plus ou moins
bien préparés
je vais juste à répondre à un truc
ouais on demande c'est quoi ce qu'on
veut dire par il calcule
en fait dans une position
en vo tu vois normalement des coûts on
va dire des coûts candidat c'est des
coups que tu estimes je vois plus comme
un petit filtre bien contrairement à un
ordi qui va analyser 100 % des coûts
possibles et les éliminer petit à petit
je verse en passant des coups possibles
un ordi laïque et noir il regardera un
coup comme vous prend 1,2 donne le fond
comme d'investissement l'adar emprise du
creux-du-van débile que nous allons
humains déjà tu tues filtre les coûts
candidats ici bas ça peut être joué 3 h
huit agents la de cette colonne ouverte
ça peut être faire cailler désistement
la route alors est ce que je fais fou
prend enfin est-ce que je pousse
ce que je fais dames c'est cette parce
qu'on a calculé rend tout nouvel os est
incomprise donc en fait on a tous ces
coups là potentiellement possible
prétend sein a priori quel est le
meilleur est ce que roy suite c'est plus
fort que dams et sait tous que quand il
décide
donc bas donc tu commences à étudier
premier donc il tient un rouage suite
qu'est ce qu'on la sort peut jouer
dessus aurait pu faire france et 4 et
peut faire tour g1 que parfois je sis en
fait la plainte branches comme ça de
partout et en fait il faut avoir de
telagh des trucs et que tu mettes des
jugements sur la position a pas juste je
regarde les coups c'est quand tu finis
ta va rien de calculé tu te dis ok ça je
suis bien ça je suis pas bien ça c'est
égal et après tu compare un peu tout ce
que tu as regardé c'est de faire le
choix qui te plaît le plus au bout du
bout quoi
et il a choisi vous prendra fin
oui puisque c'est le bon coup
je sais pas
c'est un coup c'est un coût qui se
regarde évidemment parce que au moins ça
évite de casser à tout et qui comprend
ses quatre combats être à leur envoyer
des fois ça crée un vis-à-vis de 2 sa
libération des peut-être qu'on est de
faire des quatre dans la foulée
après évidemment tu vas laisser les
blancs placer une tour soit clown f
alors est-ce que c'est celle là est ce
que c'est l'autre ça la question je
crois que le redis des tests après il
faut faire analyser bizarrement je
mettrais l'autre tour
feeling
alors dit préfère clairement ton cours
doit aimer la tour sur la colonne des
qui fait pression sur des singes
mais moi c'était l'idée en fait ouais
c'était de garder la tour là et je
m'étais dit les deux ans la figer
un calcul et scarlett le truc c'est que
maintenant si tu prends la qualité ça
doit être un problème parce qu'on peut
plus attaquer les cases noires cirque
même quand tu fais à troyes b 3 on va le
montrer lors dix ans à
faire prendre beaucoup de temps pour
ramener un cavalier ans et cinq châteaux
tempo est bon et alors alors on avait la
grande diagonale ouverte avec le rhin
qui étaient dans des réseaux de maths
marin est là les pions vous obstrué vont
gêner d'autres peut-être peuvent dès 4
ans fait sûrement pas de dégâts
mais du coup si tu fais pas des cats
c'est sûr que tout rachat fin pas le
truc c'est qu'en plus vous prenez votre
mal chronique je vous trouve bien aux
quatre
jours d'ailleurs où il viendra un f5 ce
n'est pas la meilleure décision ferait
fin mais on va voir ce qu'il va calculer
et déjà commandé pau va reprendre mais
quoiqu'il toujours pas revenues
s'asseoir non non n'est pas qu'il n'est
pas là on voit qu'ils jouent à la
politique de la chaise vide comme
souvent jan alors après je sais pas si
un écran avec les positions en salle de
repos mais qui pourrait voir le coup
lors marche bien mais c'est pas moi qui
passe
il ya plusieurs bilans attention
attention là c'est pareil on s'est déjà
fait avoir on a eu penser c'est aînés
peau et on est on s'est rendu compte
qu'il pouvait y avoir aussi dû à douala
il pouvait aussi avoir dû rajab afin
dans le règne
qui habite qu'on lui connaissait pas qui
fait plaisir bien évidemment
ni oui et non il ya doute a aussi un
yaya 3 à trois beaux buts dans ce
tournoi
la zone asie et la revue
via trois bobines
d'ailleurs peut-être en es tu nous
montres à tombeau vide au cifam
obtenons
on est poli comme ammann ne te surestime
pas à fab non mais je suis aussi
il a quand même un beau but d'un
pas sur toi pas sûr sûr tu vas falloir
manger un peu plus femme tu manges pas
assez
mais il ya un quatrième but gelé
j'ai oublié à temps il ya les peaux duda
radjabov
babacar wagane ont dit non fillon où
l'on
rapporte n'ont pas trop quoi fin nakov
amène à faire mais c'est un ex bide
énorme d'accord non non il ya trois vide
en fait seulement je suis parfois j'en
avais 4 en tête
pasqua sur fourrages 6 tu m'as serait en
fait tu veux prendre une tour auquel il
l'a fait tourner bref je pense qu'on
peut tu peux regarder je tenais juste
avec ta plus grosse turbine par
curiosité parce que la petite turbine
inquiète alors après visuellement on
peut comprendre pourquoi d'un autre côté
c'est difficile je sais que les gens
qu'ils feraient bien d'aller viser 100
turbines et où tout à la main mais là le
problème c'est que vous voyez la
complexité de la position alireza vient
de parade passé quarante minutes
pour jouer à son niveau il faudrait
qu'on passe 40 heures et on les a pas
devant nous mais pas raviver la turbine
jeunesse monte en puissance
cela n'a pas impressionné fou pour m il
aime pas
pas trop
il te dis pas que mais
pas trop ravi il veut faire jouer à
trois
dans le tchat sur quoi b3 semble logique
et dams et c'est
ça une principale juste monter dans les
tours
mais ça a l'air d'être clairement à 3
ça m'inquiète un peu un jeu te cache pas
gros joueurs un ce dépôt
c'était sans jeu de mots de base
will dragomir qui dit à 3 seul coup
d'ailleurs
ouais bon le truc en fait c'est qui
l'ordi va chercher la qualité souvent
dans les banques
3b trois dames c'est cette
fois ci seront ensuite il vous prend il
faut
et tu te dis au cas où je restais quatre
représentations je bloquerai
j'étais quand même et un bout de temps
d'ailleurs un push mais bon ça va être
chaud parce que tu vois il dit tour ces
8es liteon des six coups pour avantage
de 10 et 4
commencé à lire ses calculs si ces
quatre présentations l'homme cedh
après c'est sûr que ten dam bloqueurs
c'est pas le meilleur bloqueur 1 c'est
pas gagné d'avancé pulsions stade assez
avancé un peu les pions mais c'est dur d
avance
après ça reste compliqué
ouais je suis pas h
je suis pas catastrophé par la position
a personnellement
m 2 0 90 1 dans la mesure qu'on amène
deux ens
on n'est pas catastrophé non non non bon
après c'est a priori pas de choix le
meilleur d'après les ordis mais
en pratique d'impression à la très
compliqué
et même celle qu'on a
versé 4 et tous adams et de bloqueurs
ça fait plus que jouer
c'est très tendu et d'ailleurs ça peut
même tourner en faveur d'ali reza après
ce que j'aime pas ce qui vient de
prendre fin ton point f1 on est déjà sur
cinq minutes de réflexion là
non mais sérieux c'est mauvais signe
je suis un peu inquiet
à disons donc à huy après tous ces
cadres ont été assez content parce que
il ans après papa des positions
compliquées et c'est ça et comme tu as
dîner pour renverser la pression en
jouant vite manière intéressante
peut-être pas objectivement le plus
dangereux quoi mais en tout cas c'est
loin d'être des cours édicules et
manens yasa de trouver des coûts c'est à
lui de trouver à 3 trouver des mécènes
trouver tout ça et quand bien même on
est plutôt mauvais côtés même si ça joue
mais ça va être comparé dru et ya plus
de place aux erreurs
et on n'y a plus qu'une heure 11
mois là pour dumas inquiète pas trop
pour l'instant
2 un jeu beaucoup plus vite
nostra planus
aujourd'hui
l'alter ego
niveau c'est un taré go
[Musique]
ne sera dit c'est nostradamus
et deux frères
y en a un qui a toujours suivi l'otan
fait il n'a jamais rien moi j'ai
l'impression qu'on a plutôt le wlan us
avec nous
je autre a toujours su et c'est ça qui a
tué l'autre a toujours su est bien
trouvée à grenay qu
est ce que le bonus est plus fort que le
janus a rien n'est plus fort qu un janus
elf a besoin de l'année ça c'est fort
ingénieux va maintenant jouer cavalier
dames et cavani en plus quoi
ça peut faire mal salle un janus bref si
bête noire dans quoi bref ça être
très fort le janus
pour hafid
comment j'ai ici brashear est en fait
c'est vraiment fort à metz voilà s'il
avait un janus il serait très bien
aller en s'atténuant son nom pas sûr
d'aller mater les blancs tu sens que tu
arrives michael jasny soit efficace pour
le janus et l'ordre le crédit à 3 tu te
crées des cases pour janis à 3 apprécié
humains à troyes b 3 qui jaillit cc3c
matin matin
le schéma c'est fort un phénix
tu me donnes un janus je vais pas
n'importe qui je pense beaucoup trop
fort dans à jamais sa part adam
non
il s'agit des fous plus cavalier enfin
non nous on a déjà lu spéciaux quoi
jadis pimpé s'emmerde pas
déjà fou plus qu'à valises pas
d'une très belle pièce
saison qui réfléchissent autant gérer
autant il peut javier ses variantes ok
je peux faire ça
inquiétant
non mais en fait il fait exactement la
même chose que ce qu'il a fait contre
radjabov quand dans la séquence où il a
mal joué
en fait quand il fait ça c'est mauvais
signe
qu'on le dise non réfléchis plus
une pression non je suis pas peut-être
mais je crois pas la position très
compliqué justin
mais quand il fait ça il rate un truc
mais j'imagine fait j'y ai cru quand il
fait ça je sais pas ce qui se passe
vraiment dans le fond de de son cerveau
mais c'est qu'il ya quelque chose qui
ne va pas dans ses calculs ou
c'est je n'arrive pas à l'expliquer pour
le moment on ne connaît pas encore assez
peut-être mais mais c'est mauvais signe
en tout cas généralement quand il a fait
ça il a mal joué bas d'ailleurs la foux
point f1 ce n'est pas un bon coup et
généralement ils enchaînent les mauvais
coups quand il plonge dans une très
longue réflexion
en plus mais peu à peu leur très
impressionné par fo prend fin
son visage voitures
et de jouer vite la bonne réponse
kg quand on a parlé tout à l'heure c'est
pas un coup qui fait vraiment sens parce
que c'est pas la priorité en fait contre
sens
non mais à 3 il faut en fait en réalité
puisque de toute façon des trois ça
marchera jamais
donc tu as besoin 2 à 3 pour b3 et et
affaiblir au moins des cases
way the remix
un plan typique faire à trois comme ça
vous avez versé 15 noir et je vais
dessus un jour surtout dans ceux qui
jouent l arroseur
souvent utilisée par les noirs pour
l'occasion
je sais pas qui l'a pas
mais ce qu'il a aujourd'hui ici dans
cette quatrième partie des candidats
alors partie
importantissime comme toutes les parties
j'ai envie de dire mais tant qu'on reste
à 50% on est assez bien surtout qu ali
reza beaucoup et les noirs après perdre
une partie surtout contre un adversaire
direct ce serait une très mauvaise
nouvelle parce qu'un l'iresa se retrouve
à un point et demi des pommiers h est
donc réellement distance et
de la tête du tournoi alors après il
restera bien sûr beaucoup plus les
blancs et et cetera mais
bon oui dans c'est pas terrible de
perdre
surtout quand ce n'est pas parce que des
pots et il a déjà plus un c'est à plus 2
il prendrait le large
le joueur russe
mais maintenant
nous on dresse des pièces complètement
prend là
bas on est d'accord que c'est une
expression prendre le large qui vient
se passe dans les régions maritimes
n'ont pas eu l'argent là bas je pense
que oui
tu es au large
je suis plus là je m'échappe comme
des athées un truc qui fait vraiment
peur c'est compter sur un bateau la nuit
j'étais sur un bateau la nuit ah oui et
non oui madonna
ça fait fifa sur un candidat sur un gros
bateau sur un petit bateau c'est sur un
gros sur un gros bateau ce qu'il ya plus
de lumière en fait est là et enfin pas
vraiment l'impression qu'il ya plus rien
et là et en fait on vient de nulle part
mais vraiment
c'est c'est assez effrayant non les
bateaux que j'ai pris ce thème alors
c'est une fois je suis allé de longs
temps de 2,7 au maroc à 10
heures
et sinon le fait que lorsqu'on est passé
par être la même impression j'étais
petit bateau
tu as lycées terrifiant d'être entouré
par de l'eau sans rien voir vraiment en
fait il ya des requins crois
en toi de requins
et puis surtout que le site a un
problème
c'est un peu aussi le lot quoi
pas pour aquaman
ni l'homme poisson à
ce qu'ils regardent se voit et je
déteste ces personnes mais je pense
qu'il est fait exprès pour être aidé
c'est un
hasard va être qu'un jour en fait parce
que là
est très con
exactement
[Musique]
massa est intéressante avec ce jeudi ses
comptes il a mangé la pareille à
poulpe
est plus vivant 1
stream spy saison de abbaoui mais bon
pour apprendre révèle pas trop
l'intriguent avec mongin poule
ouais il joue très bien l'acteur qui
joue à mulder vraiment on en discutait
hier soir est très bonne car
je pense que là c'est beaucoup moins
bien sans lui a clairement je te dis pas
qu'il tient la série puisque
l'aca grande pas surfaite sont
intéressants il joue vraiment très bien
vu
son niveau de jeu d'acteur sur ce rôle
est assez impressionnant ce qui réussit
à faire d'un personnage qui peut être
détestable d'un côté mais a réussi à le
rendre vain on comprendrait était stable
mais on comprend un peu pourquoi il fait
ça
c'est fou h 6 alors oui non ou hi5 ou
pas envie de faire juste pour bien placé
ne vous pressez pas une menace
dramatique d'aller prendre cette qualité
on a regardé déjà pas de vendre dessus
simplement parce qu'en fait les normands
reprend alors certaines qualités de
moins mais la taxe endiguer la faiblesse
c'est g7 tu vois très bien la tenir ta
job cavalli tam foot à tout le monde et
l'idée dé nord justement c'est pour ça
qu'on veut qu'ils jouent à 3 et ordi
réclame ce coup c'est que une fois que
tu fais à 3
noir tu provoques b3 en vo un état des
trous sur cases noires donc le comme les
blancs lâcher leur fou
tour à tour du con tre jeu avec une dame
qui peut s'infiltrer un jour ton fut un
cavalier peut-être et à des
compensations pendant longtemps
voilà donc
bon on fasciste c'est pas une masse à
pasaia une qualité un
hoax arènes dramatique en même temps ça
excite à elle pas faire ton contre je
attaqué le roi blanc que tu as cassé 3 à
long terme a été sur une qualité je
pense que tu parles exactement comme ça
je me permets de te lire maintenant ok
là je crois que terry flatt hélas hélas
c'est idéal je pense là à ce que je
regarde depuis tout à l'heure en fait
je regarde le vu m et là en fait la
latte à la position idéale aérodynamique
bien placé ouais là c'est parfait tu
bouges plus je vais bouger chaque fois
je ferai des petites pirates comme ça je
reviendrai comme ça et en fait tu peux
enfin c'est à la bonne distance là
étaient tous bien t'es bonne distance
mais tu peux le tenir en fait avec la
nature si tu suis un domingo par exemple
tu tends la main et un hibou cela fait
un peu le réseau lit
la terrasse avec un petit mal de dos un
peu un peu campé sur ouais mais tu peux
lever et après je vais comme ça je cède
ma vache hier je me fasse un peu
je me suis je pars je prend le micro à
bonne distance
voilà parfait
je crois qu'on tient quelque chose
par exemple à réussir sur les fesses
mais pour avoir pour la même taille que
toi mais là on a on n'a pas ça on n'a
pas ça proches
je pense juste comme ça
je pense
rizzoli à 75,68 qui n'a pas l'arrêt
forêt faut être faut être votre bonheur
complètement
sans être jamais même moi je sais trés
tutti canti et locaux on a le même agent
d'une façon
mais bon on était très heureux ben moi
j'étais très agile f
[Musique]
alors alors dit harrington baghana pions
alors pourquoi c'est intéressant ils
filent un punto
fabi mais il a une idée hein c'est sûr
est ce que cet homme c'est d'eux que
c'est à 4 cette année ces deux dames à
5,2 mds et transport mais bon je sais
pas si j'avance pas même sa pas pourquoi
je m'en serais pas même ce serait que
plus
on s'est peut-être pas d'âme ses deux
mais attend va voir à pas trop ça va
jouer on va voir
on peut les mettre en grand ouais ok dit
mme qui prend de punto partie importante
parce que ding peut ramener le peloton à
50% un procès bon en fait il est dans le
groupe derrière le gruppetto et j'ai les
fortes à carla est issu
enfin se faire décrocher du groupe
nepomniachi fabiano attention il est pas
bien
assez ta cage mais dans tous les cas on
top oui pourquoi pas un nazi et
un ordi dit bêtement b3 enfin c'est tout
con mais ces deux c2 mais à mon avis
c'est juste un mec à des gâteries défend
à baic avait trois je sais pas c'est
gagnons pas parce que les pièces noires
sont bien placés mais je pense qu'il a
bien fait
bah je pense aussi surtout que ding
s'est levé tout de suite en mode frère
qu'est ce qui t'as foutu
à mais regarde il ya une autre chasse ah
oui la sécheuse on l'avait pas vu haha
ça change tout sarah dans ce tournoi
c'est la met sa chaise rigole plus ah
bah oui en fait il a prise en salles
d'attentes
ah bah voilà à bas le tournoi est
complètement lancé fab voilà il eut
trois jours quatre jours d'acclimatation
décalage horaire il a sa chaise on ne
peut plus arriver quoi chez ed à prévoir
est-ce que
mais en fait ils n'ont pas tout à fait
les mêmes sièges même peut-être à bayard
ça va être compliqué ballon de commenter
les parties femme là c'est beaucoup trop
important de non en fait ils ont tous
pris la même chose sauf 12
aubry favori du public digne je pense
qu'il a dû changer en fait parce que les
autres jouent on n'a pas remarqué on
l'aurait remarqué à ces magnifiques en
fait changement de chaises pour pour le
joueur chinois
mais déjà une saisissante ya deux jours
m on n'avait pas vu je suis pas mais
c'est vrai qu'avec là tu as du mal a
commenté les chaises il s'attarde à
d'autres détails hu est beaucoup moins
important
façon ça tu joues à la chaise mais il me
fait peur là ali reza effet voir juste
logique est vite fait
[Musique]
gattaca qui
rapporte naka
bon
ça va toujours très bien pour naka
hockey
what else 12h et l'après même si c'est
un peu le genre de position qu'ont très
changeants voulait voir et ça joue
[Musique]
la seule partie pour le moment qui
semble pouvoir les autres ça joue mais
ça lui semble y avoir quelque chose
c'est vraiment la partie de dingle il a
joué à quatre mais
trois
acer qui considèrent caruana wimdu c'est
fabien ce n'est vraiment pas grand chose
surtout contre un trail comme ding qui
ne comprend vraiment rien mais non en
fait c'est quelque chose grâce avions
simplement plus douaniers
shampooing qui aurait dû revenir là bas
donc
7 sur 10 let's go allez y pour avoir une
journée parfaite fopac alireza la perdre
pour nous le problème en fait c'est pas
c'est pas les échiquiers à côté parce
que la cidi mieux gagne même si nul ça à
la fin là il ramène tout le monde en
fait digne qui ramène tellement peloton
et l'a fait l'effort pour le vaudois
après faut pas qu'ils se grille non plus
dans sureau border
sera ok tant d'échecs sera comme ça
quand tu as gagné une partie tu sues
lendemain de nouveau dans le groupe et
hommage à son frère hani fiq vos échecs
tu peux faire un truc je ne peux pas
trop je ramène le groupe et refait une
attaque lorraine direct là tu peux pas
trop tu vas te mettre un peu dans les
roues et
la nature le parage if we du toupet
latine fusée c'est le genre de feuilles
de l'on dise quoi il parle en soit être
soit sa taille et poids de
la folie mais bon vernis colles quoi
pour
la m
07 me mets tout seul contre un peloton
sur le sur 50 km ça me fait dans le
plaindre et des centres partout
ouah
ouais à les raisins
49,58 de réflexion plus ou moins sur
cette position puisqu'à partir depuis
faux procès fin je considère que c'est
la même position ça commence à sentir le
roussi it's my the roussy comme disent
les américains
utilisent
d'ailleurs fort bien joué
sur le moment c'était magnifique enfin
une attaque de prestige on connaît la
suite
alireza pourrait peut-être changer de
chaise voilà des bons conseils
non mais tu vois je n'étais pas trop
dedans sont des candidats trop de choses
pareilles mais là tout est relancé avec
cette chaise de loading relance
complètement le tournoi
on va avoir des chèques champagne et je
pense
à woody crois pas
pour moi le titre one donc d'un gi qui
marche mais là je crois que des
boulevards suis pas malin aujourd'hui je
vois pas trois sites
d'accueil ce qui marche bien
aucune idée
c'est pas un bon marcheur il n'y a pas
de tel marcheurs te guérit et maxime
et maxime les deux leaders
de l'asean mais je crois pas non enfin
pas vous on n'a pas accès a en fait
pour faire simple
on ne peut pas faire une régie total
avec 18 caméras il ya trop de bugs ya
trop de trucs qui vont pas enfin en vrai
ce serait faisable mais il aurait fallu
qu'ils se tapent tout différemment et de
la manière qui est qui a été fait pour
les régies il y aurait trop de risques
que ça bug
donc non
papa papa pourra pas pour le moment
hello j'arrive j'entends cheyrou déjà à
la peine c'est quoi le bail sur des
preuves ou là des prendre ça doit être
tamis g2 je pense
touche-à-tout la dame qui a 9 5 qui
arrive n'est peut-être pas mal direct
mais
ça j'ai même pas envie de regarder un
coup de plus non mais en vo patrick ewen
7e 4 pourquoi gdf 6 et
tattoo qui se posera qui quoi
la merde
c'est trop et n'oubliez pas ça la
diagonale
donc ça va pas en fait ça va pas des
points
en fait le coup à faire a priori avec
l'ordi mais c'est logique un jeu d re
même humainement 7,43 aucun
affaiblissement murdoch des blancs qui
vont faire un b3 pour wii et jardins de
ces sept
on va avoir accès peut être à jouer
cette pièce c3s que les ventes vont
reprendre et si on peut faire du foie
justice après un problème ils peuvent
gagner une qualité 1 évidemment j'aurais
un couple si
mais bon
bon les blancs sont vieux mais à quel
point je suis
très vite
on aa destructeur
je ne sais pas evora presque c4 est
obligé mais bon évidemment ça pousse
nicolas rente loin et puis roudet et de
se demander ce que j'ai vraiment bonne
qualité on pas et vous verrez tout ça
c'est évident
il est donc dur là très clairement
maintenant oui
oui c'est une très longue réflexion et
ouais il est pas confortable il était au
début quand tu puis c'est tout
enfin on dit dans le chatt isin de
tarbes
mais bon il va fin du bizet tout à
l'heure où il va pas être mal au temps
où quoi la 50 minute pour 19 coups dans
une position aussi complexe est ce que
tu commences finalement un peu su au thé
où tu continues à non mais je suis pas
ben
ouais les mineurs 40g pas qu'il ait joué
au con 50 ministres est-ce que tu as
padres et c'est ça le fait d'avoir vu
les deux premières parties
lensois ça va ça qu'on trouve un coup
encore trop molle un peu quand même on
veut des coups bas mais la position
reste ultra complexes femmes
ab après bon de jouer vite et bien
on va devoir choisir entre un truc pas
terrible un autre podium à votre package
vers le meilleur dans tout ça aucun des
quatorze besson légal ou pas mais c'est
loin de jouer tu as fait ta connerie
tueur fou c'est fait
c'est pas c'est pas si grave
surtout que je rappelle qu'il a réfléchi
quand même un long moment avant foot.fr
donc logiquement tu aurais dû savoir ce
que tu fais surtout rage pour f1 mais je
vais ailleurs c'est pas la première fois
qu'il fait ça avec là aussi c'est comme
si raté un coup logique apte à cannes
avec le tour des
voix là ça donne cette impression quand
même parce que tu tangue pas une demi
heure sur foot pro f 1 r e fin héros une
demi-heure sur tous âges point f1 c'est
quand même spécial
sonoco kg 4 on va parler plein de fois
c'est juste ça fait pas que 500 fait
rien on s'en fout train de se [ __ ]
tour j'y arrive
je sais pas vous
voilà ta dessin
reprend des singes verdelhan temps de le
faire
c'est dégueulasse en fait donc et g4 la
danse il ya des cas où évident kg 4 ça
fait plaisir même si sienna est
reprendre ce fou mais là il ya trop
d'autres enjeux de la pression pourrait
perdre de temps juste pour comprendre
souciant un pion angers7
ce serait différent mais là il ya
d'autres priorités on n'a pas le temps
en fait le temps n'a pas tant pour le
temps
il fait flipper la fille roux est là il
fait il fait flipper il fait flipper le
dauphin
si peur
il va jouer à trois je pense ok on
souffre lot quand même c'était le coup
c'était le seul coup un pour elle c'est
dans la partie fo ne faut le dire
il pour un peu d'eau il inquiète regarde
à la petite gorges est comme ça
inquiétude
une petite table basse
par terre
je sais pas j'ai pas l'impression de se
pencher jusqu'au sol la presse une
tablette à une tablette
car on l'appelle dans le champenois
john me poggia débarqué de détroit tembo
par commune tant elle va arriver mais on
va le voir on va devoir tout d'un coup
comme une furie
non c'était beaucoup trop maigre
aucun respect
en plus ce n'est pas posée la tombe et
dallas 3
avec cette chemise blanche
souvent en dehors
non mais tu vois c'est non et d'appeler
la bouteille je crois qu'il ya deux
bides je demande a ralenti sa marche à
fond non non c'est pas lui c'est radja
serradj à genève où il a posé la beauté
faute
bon outil mais il me posais métal droite
juste pauleta bouteille
ou alors c'est le porteur d'eau qui est
venu me qui viennent dépôt qui est
remonté pour le poser sa bouteille d'eau
metalor faire ça gentil posta bouteilles
sont absolument rien à [ __ ] et
[Musique]
c'était beau ben c'est vrai il a posé la
bouteille tu as raison mais il en a
absolument à la fin de la partie en fait
c'est assez exceptionnel
je peux lui partie
jeu qu'on suive le billet va être caméra
4 je pense
à cénac à
doit chercher la nana sixième sous type
l'intéressé n'a qu'à l'occasion
plus que la sienne
normale en attendant en même temps faby
[Musique]
quattro mais il est pas bien fait bien
non
[Musique]
richards
24 ans qu'il
sait qu'il va finir pas favoris de ce
tour
je pense c'est bien joué de la part de
djédjé mady
dewey je veux faire des tours j'ai cinq
appels
à saveur de boeuf aujourd'hui les
patrons souffrance
c'était très important pour lui qu'ahmed
haroun partie marque bien
ça dure aux caisses à la
jaille vécu amoindri les pas encore
largué
on n'y a aucune explication au coût de 2
caruana il a du mal jugé la position
raté quelque chose parce que là c'est
juste un punto à l'autre cas c'est juste
qu'il peut être été trop et c'est ok
vaut mieux ça que la colonne ses
analyses
on peut pas dire ça comme ça au pied
levé
ou alors il a fait une connerie et
plutôt parce que
c'était sa position
mais quand même les peaux c'est
particulier de d'être venu d'or faisait
la bouteille de s'être barré il aller
chier c'est pas possible non mais je
veux dire là au bout d'un moment j'ai un
jeu je comprends pas
on sait pas en fait il est même content
car cette
poser des questions
déjà mellacois fait
mais il va chier
avait pas tout vendre
non mais là je les pages et au final
j'ai jamais vu quelqu'un faire ça en
partie genre il est passé devant sata
avec le coup joué ya réellement cinq
minutes
j'ai pas d'autre explication
avant
non messieurs en salle de pause ça
devrait réellement être interdits en
fait par la fille de bout d'un moment tu
peux pas dire dress code anaqua et
laisser quelqu'un
ne pas être nominée réfléchir la salle
de repos c'est il ya un problème quelque
part
mais surtout qu'on va dire
je baissais madame on signe aussi
voulait
alors que
c'est moi c'est un poème de réglage
caméras mais c'est un peu faim ah oui
mais si je vais essayer mais juste c'est
pas facile à régler comme on avait
d'autres soucis
mais je vais pas pour le régler partout
voilà règle et là
ça ils sont contents je dépends dépôt
qui est pas là en fait si jamais on
n'avait pas vu passer dans le champ de
la caméra
d'ailleurs il n'a pas vu que tout allait
alors vraiment passer à la table pour
des sabotages donc il sait que ça le jeu
ouais mais s'il faut le faire sur toutes
les scènes et
[Musique]
et on veut regarder les parties quand
même
complexe
en tout cas la position dure déjà joué
le coup
des chances pratique dans la position
bien joué de sa part il s'est bien
repris après le fou prend effet un pas
top
s'ils jouent tempo c'est qu'ils
regardaient pas traîné
c'est quand même particulier
après quoi d'autres
ce n'est juste pas envie qu'ils aient à
apprendre d'eux ça ouvre la colonne
damas un de l'arrivée ça va attaquer à
deux donc
à trois jouets b3 joué par dont
ali reza devrait revenir habiter devrait
jouer tempo siro réfléchi 20 minutes là
dessus je comprends plus rien aux
expressive à tembo peut-être pas mais
deux minutes action
en face il y avait quoi borne spéciale
mais après
oui alireza
il a fait trop de temps femme
a le temps ça va ça va là il a réfléchi
beaucoup je pense qu'il va enchaîner une
séquence une séquence de
leroy h8 de tam c7 le tour c'est 8 de
coupe tu
vas nous faire ces trois coups d'affilée
assez rapidement à mon avis
allez y les il est de retour à la table
bay 3 c'était le coût attendu
ben joue
j'ai pas envie que fin 45 minutes soit
18 coups ça va encore mais si tu leur
tante 15 ou 20 minutes là on va quand
même s'inquiéter un moment donné non
mais quinze minutes là c'est pas
possible on va voir mais
je pense que max ferme l'a43 la pendule
de leur âge où et quoi encore 45
je vois pas affiché à plus de trois
minutes sur
parce que juste en fait b300 seul coup
en fait tu te fasses à ce que tu vas
jouer ensuite
citons un pion dans sa main un dépôt
j'ai pas ce que ça veut dire mais il
tournait alors il a deux bouteilles
l'accueil à un terme au stress et le
café là il a le café l'eau en fait c'est
un pique nique bientôt il va sortir le
petit réchaud way from hell affaire à
une raclette
et boudry à ta petite raquette miniature
au dessus du jogo fidh août à petit des
petits mini four à pizza est un et tu te
fais des petits machins pendant la
partie
madonna petite charcuterie machaâl
gauche sortie jambon cru ta vraie
réserve la viande des grisons
si c'était comme ça tu serais 2008
femmes
non emerson noter pour ton choix de d à
d'immenses et pour ton bide
non mais c'est hallucinant à troyes b
3-1 dans la gestion du temps elle est
quand même pittoresque
je sais pas quoi +63 je suis tout
d'abord ou je sais pas quoi mais bon
faut pas trop à feu chargées 10,43 matt
encore 45 secondes pour veut
[Musique]
le truc en plus c'est que si sûr à trois
baies 3 tu t'es step a décidé qu'est ce
que t'as foutu pour un bleu à de
meilleures routes a réfléchi
arrête ou alors tu as que fait paris vi
nations et que tout est pourri sauf à 3
mais
c'est particulier quand même la gestion
du temps d'alireza autant les prépas je
trouve très impressionnant autant le
milieu de jeu
ils étaient plus forts aux grands
suisses même si c'était combat personnel
c'est ça ouais mais bon là il ya quand
même quelque chose femmes
regards 3 entretien il n'a pas joué
attend certes il va re claqué minimum
trois minutes alors qu'il reste moins de
trois minutes par coup sur le coup le
plus évident après lequel il vient de
dépenser
une heure quasiment pour fou prendrait
fin à trois et tu sais que tu oublies
c'est exactement ses effets contre hadja
mafoula vers claqué 20 minutes sur le
coup pareil en fait
là c'est tout racheté fin qui n'est pas
évident pour moi a priori entre tours
détours est
un peu la position ça devient clair et
p3c il n'y a pas de chance
non mais surtout qu'en plus dont il a
fait à trois baies 3 humaine et il s'est
paré 10 ou 15 minutes
non plus sinon
10 seraient dépouillés par 1500
reprendre une plombe je pense qu'il me
guettait de loin et voit qu'il n'est pas
là oui mais bon si tu sais pas ce que tu
feras sur b3 tu as quand même le droit
directrice - non mais bien réfléchi
sur du temps a pas l'air optimale
même et reprend un pion dans sa main
quoi
ils m'inquiètent 1 aujourd'hui je suis
très inquiet la
voix la position à la position des temps
durs à vrai dire
normalement
vieux blanc n'est pas beaucoup
très compliqué plein de choses va être
le gros du groupe a n'a pas encore
commencé ça le problème et
12 par ville s'inquiète aussi pour la
pendule parce que ben oui ça va encore
chauffer et
oracle armand des moments critiques
ensuite on va prendre des vraies bonnes
décisions et donc sept minutes
importantes
chaque seconde compte
quoi qu évident aux demandes non médias
pas du tout évident soit ici ça peut
être suite ça peut être dames c'est cet
a priori
bénigne
en fait en soi c'est pas fassions de
pause la position de but en blanc
maintenant tu peux pas répondre en deux
minutes mais en fait il vient de jouer à
trois avant et b3 sur le coup du l'objet
dont 40 à la suite en fait
trop trop de réflexion après avant goût
de ce
site fait une super 5 ans après on va
pardonner
c'est juste tous les jours en fait
si c'est une fois
et 1 qu'est ce qui se passe du côté de
digne très tranquille ding balle un
jeune à paris on te qu'on avait supposé
des vieux
enfin guéri 1 il a vendangé contreras
porte
c'est pas leur position c'est plus
technique
le contrat porte ou faire quelques
calculs et s'est un peu embrouillé on va
dire rater les ordres calcul
c'est dans ses cordes du ring de
richard rapporte on va pas rester
longtemps sur la position parce que
entre la casse a l'air assez égal et du
coup on va aller jeter un oeil à un ou
deux
on est toujours au point mort même
position la pâleur a bien non il n'a pas
l'air ravi radjabov qui fait sa partie
on va retourner
chez relier resa du coup et et attendre
impatiemment son cours il est dos au mur
un ca fait ça fait déjà sept minutes
qu'il est maintenant sur ce coup
l'inquiétude est à son comble fabien
je suis papa toujours inquiets mais mais
c'est que cette histoire de cadence en
rajoutant ça change des choses il n'y a
pas trente secondes parcourant jusqu'au
40e donc
[Musique]
jusqu'au temps en temps normal avec ses
trente secondes c'est à 30 secondes à la
pendule sa c3 pourra jouer
un dernier coup ça va quoi ces deux
minutes qu'a duré la
3 coûte
t il à plus de 38 30 pour 18 coup on se
répète beaucoup un là dessus mais ça
pourrait être un élément déterminant et
surtout que ça caractérise aussi et ça
souligne le fait que qu'ils soient pas
dans son assiette parce que quand on a
des positions qu'on arrive à jouer où je
vis tu peux tu as de dante à des
réflexes
blazers qu'il est mal à l'aise et qui
sent mal dans la position la qualité
mais l'érable a été peut-être au point
fr est là qu il a clairement sous-estimé
ou ratées tourache point f1 probablement
sous-estimé simplement
un coup que iana a joué lui
vit très rapidement et
il lui reste maintenant plus de deux
minutes park ou encore on dit dans le
chat
sait peu
sur toute la pollution va pas simplifier
il a joué roi a ensuite haussé bien
il à cliquer un des bons coups de la
position peut-être même le meilleur
hockey dépôt
s'attendait vite en fait sur la clique 1
il en a absolument rien à [ __ ] n'est
pas mon avis
alors il a voulu assez vite moi il ya en
pour cliqua
tempo minatchy comme on l'appelle dans
le milieu
l'homme qui n'en avait rien à [ __ ] de
réfléchir
il a l'air à l'asian
sa clique
il va se barrer
la dame s'est certes c'est seul coup
d'après le redis encore mais bon c'est
une couleuvre logique en même temps
je te cache pas que là sont tellement
pas cette game
c'est une dinguerie
je la sens tellement pas
elle est vraiment très inquiétante
4 compliqué en fait après adams et 7 cm
logique et trop précises
parce que tu force ou prend il à fourche
est souffrant
on voulait montrer
et de coup l'option des ducs analyse moi
donc il peut avancer tu peux te faire
bouffer p4 des sites à tripoli tu prends
la grèce d'une cavale est resté huit
camps
d'am-dam c6 peut-être b4
du coup on matériel un pion pour la
qualité un roi plutôt bien avec les
blancs mais qu'est ce que ça donne
objectivement je sais pas il surfe ou g7
pour jouer f5 avec un management /
je sais pas qui
tu veux être
prête à 17 art
c'est compliqué en fait je dire
conclusions
ouais c'est pas si clair
mais c'est dangereux
bon je vais tourner un peu lors d'une
impression un petit peu avant au lieu
des 6 le théâtre et tu dis que tu es 3
pu être mieux même ses sept tours prend
f6
peut-être qu'il y ait des trois
des six tubes elles font ces 5
et tu prends du fonds p4 et peut-être
faire ces 5 c 4 7 5 des trucs
aussi complet enfin en fait en soit je
suis pas sûr qu'un morceau si mal un
ordi mais que les blancs sont mieux mais
bon
et oui ça va être un gros combat hélas
le temps évidemment va être important et
des décisions importantes
surtout que la ire autant qu en fait
en attendant pendant qu'on a parlé de
prendre des cinq étaient quand même le
seul coup sûr watch 8 ils firent d'euros
il va reprendre encore dix minutes
j'aurais à bout d'un moment
rappelle toi qui devait y donner je
reste et 43 minutes
avant on va ensuite un
essai de nouveau la séquence principale
donc excusez moi monsieur mais je
m'inquiète
c'est louis la position soit ballet
compliqué peut pas dire qu'il soit mieux
d'ailleurs l'ordi préfère un petit peu
des plans je vous le redis mais quand on
la voit à nous avec les humains qui est
juste pour faire oublier voilà et
[Musique]
la pendule
à nos problèmes
chose qui va pas
dans le calcul ya ait eu un oubli
quelque part il ya un problème il ya une
position qui lui plaît pas il ya
[Musique]
la position à part de leurs valets mais
ça c'est sûr mais dans tout ce que je
voyais et peut-être que t'es pas faim je
vous redis leur dis que c'est mieux donc
je peux pas on découvre un ordi je veux
lui faire confiance mais il te plaît pas
plus 5 quoi ça
après peut-être que il voit qu'il fait
bloquer qui fait jamais son f5 vous
faire et que tu dis est vu comme ça on
se dit que même brouillé peut-être passé
ouais
et dc c'est pas bon coup
ma faim
en fait perdre b4 c'est un peu chiant
parce que des fois autant on aime bien
perdre des pions quand on est en
recomposant pour mettre des tours sur
les colonnes et la colonne b assez
inutile parce que là des blindés donc en
fait c'est vraiment perdre le pion
peut-être qu'on va se faire bouffer à
trois aussi un jour et surtout l'absence
de plan b 4 ça lance le pion ses débuts
l'an dernier en c4 c5 plus sales point
que la disparition du pillon b4 en
lui-même c'est super plaisant place en
quoi et on
n'a pas de découvertes fantastiques et
donc c'est problématique mois
a priori non
[Musique]
jean retour à 5h tour à cela
qu'un pion
problèmes aux
[Musique]
jambes jours avant par l'élimination là
en fait en fait d'amener cette tu va me
trouver parce que dès 6h poste que des
âmes c'est
fou prend
jugé que sa section ouais mais en fait
quand même six qualifiés 3 tu mets
laurent a quant lui qui allait en dame
prend encore adam ces trois dames b2 il
faut trouver calais b 5 c'est pas facile
hein et aurait fait feu
pardon je suis content il a joué je
crois que je vais qui avait décidé que
c'est déjà foutu
ouais c'est évident farooq a appris la
trompette et des six ouais donc signer
pouvois dames 3 et 4 c'est pas un coin
visible à l'air de bien se passer pour
les noirs du tout
juste courson nc c'est tout ce n'est pas
si clair
là ça a l'air complètement fini juste en
fait
well done +3 26,1 sur d'improbables
3,50
à windham premier 4 sa sucession tous
les problèmes des blancs comme on disait
le problème c'est que tant qu'il ya ce
pion en b 4 ça fixe option ces deux
donne accès à la casse ces trois bons
pour faire cailler b5 et contre je
cabello 4
du coup le bouffer un souffle c'est
ensuite du matin durant ces 4 sera très
solide ça va aussi avancé la marée et
donc
je sais pas très mauvaise partie pour le
mandat les raisins parce que si on se
dit que sa prépa en gros ce à partir du
carré gée crois que commence à réfléchir
attends tu as choisi le coq guen et on
peut dire que les deux marches donc on
va dire que c'est le premier mois tu
veux faire une faute est en fait en un
an fait l'enchaînement de coup tu peux
pas être perdant plus vite que ça en
fait non loin de donner à voir un des
poids qualité ce fameux premier 4 mai va
le faire
enfin le cook a manqué c'était qu'un
valet v5 qui n'était pas facile
à s'était pas passé
mais ça s'est senti un que
qu'il y avait un problème pour ali reza
qui trouvait pas ou
alors plus de me tromper que tu
vas tu vas plus rien à voir après
quoi faire d'autre avec les blancs la
gamine à ce caillou 4
et 5 il doit quand même avoir une idée
pratique pas si simple à contrer c'est
impossible
parce qu'il a raté c'est vraiment
tourache point f un
tas de base ainsi on revient sur la
partition réfléchit le ton réflexion oui
des six dans certaines ignore même pot
n est pas facile aujourd'hui pour la
fois jouer vite
et ma posture la libye lot
pas la posture confiante
la leçon
niveau en fait comme comme l'année
dernière au candidat très impressionnant
pour le moment
normalement il à supporter cette
pression là
il a l'air tellement facile
mais là je sais pas ce qui peut trop
jouer avec les noirs
t'as pas de découvertes intéressantes
déjà cet oubli donc peut-être prêtre qui
allie et si tu fais 5 ok là 17
c4
presque déjà à temps d'abandonner ça va
trop vite
je sais pas quoi dire pour ton salaire
ya un banni des pratiques
trop plomber 4 qui disparaît
à la tâche et un truc en c3 tapis on
sait qui tu arrives dans un étrange
c'est peu probable
deux gros problèmes
laflaque ac3 t'as plus rien
et tu as trouvé un tour des stades en
attendant qui joue et on va voir la
compromis
oui
encore un peu tendre alireza
rien qui va tenter de sauver son truc et
il émane
pas encore foutu évidemment c'est plus
facile simple d'avancé pour la tour f 1
elle doit garder f2 qui est le cas très
actif et vanessa tout faire du h 5 h 4 h
trois quarts des trouvères droit des
choses comme ça donc c'est pas encore
pas encore fait mais sûrement sur un
très bon jeu des blancs ouais
ok
n'a qu'à
contrôler
avec corinne en tchat c'est réfléchir
après d'un premier cas ce que c'est
quand même le coup à regarder basse et
c'est vrai c'est ça qui est étonnant sur
toute la partie c'est que des pots à
jouer que les coups les plus évidents à
chaque fois il a fait tanguer entre dix
et trente minutes anyresa donc ses fins
il passe vraiment à côté de la partie en
fait parce qu'il n'aime pas sa position
ouais
il a prévu un truc à eux il n'était pas
au fait
tu cherches tu cherches tu vois pas
mieux rejoindre le truc tu aurais fait
ouais mais qui devra quand même pas en
fait
c'est que ça chaque convention ouais
donc le tout d'abord en fait ça joue ça
va pas forcément faire nul direct merad
j'avais fait pas mal sont restés en
sécurité va évidemment tout ait un
envoyé le pion à pour les ouvrir les
lignes à des
bricoleurs du jour enfin faty oui si la
dame prenne fin évidemment c'est vers un
nul 2 2 et 3 des échanges des dames donc
il peut se passer des choses tout poil
la vidéo du sens ça continue comme ça je
pense que le titre ça va être un gouffre
les sépare
avec un gouffre entre parce qu'il a déjà
battu à bucarest dans une position
compliquée où il a surclassé et la
sicile regagne comme ça c'est pas quand
même 2 0 n'est faux contre ali reza et
deux fois dans des positions
way est compliquée où ali reza est censé
être son point fort et oui ce fut
nettement sur place et plate a vraiment
l'impression qu'un gouffre les sépare
encore
voila voila il va déjà pas être parti
alors est ce que il va nous faire mentir
et va trouver les ressources pour faire
objectivement ses positions est mauvaise
mais après des joueurs sont à l'aise qui
montre des ressources qui te poussent
comme des problèmes et comme on n'est
pas des ordi on a du mal à clarens si
les blancs en fait c'est plus entre les
mains nues beaucoup de choses bougent
dans le bon coup il va gagner
essayez de l'année justement a dérapé à
problèmes
et j'ai du mal à voir proposer à ses 4,5
en fait
un coup franc un bide comme
on dit le jeu de dépôt lui convient pas
on va le truc c'est qu'il essaye femmes
ça me ferait penser à quelqu'un qui
prendrait nadal
en coup droit lifté
match ouais alors tu dis oui c'est mon
point fort je vais jouer contre rafa là
dessus et puis en fait parce pas que tu
joues mal en fait c'est que l'autre est
tellement bon dans ce que tu fais
que il faudrait quand même que tu
bifurquer que vous une petite karokhail
petit filet elle est mon truc c'est
quand finalisation avec comme t'as pas
de finale paraît je comprends en fait
son problème c'est que
juste être pas de secteur de jeu où il
peut vraiment encore rivaliser avec
l'époux puisque dépôts en finale en plus
on technique n'est pas me donner on le
prend juste pour un crew qui attaquent
mais en fait un nom techniquement il est
vendu au monde une épaule n'a rien fait
l'a sefyu qui perd tout seul van époque
et ce qu'il a fait il a joué tous les
coups logique tempo quand même et il
fait pas d'erreur enfin rien frein aux
échecs ne pas faire d'erreur c'est quand
même pas mal généralement surtout des
pulsions compliquer
les affaires tour suivant ses coups que
je pensais avec l'idée sur ses cadres
d'avoir quatre ans et 4
ok allez faut espérer un choc un
césar votre main facile
après c'est le genre de position ont
alors dit dans quel +4
je pense on arrive à donner plus plus un
couple 6 déjà
du dôme quatre ans qu'elle donne fou b6
des couvertures des m17
il fait à main ok mais ça c'est pas
facile puisque la moins j'aurais pensé
cavani ces quatre
décès tourbe et
8-k mali b3 ok mais ça c'est pas évident
évident
voit que quand on met trois éléments
cadres grave alors c'est pas dur en fait
ouais il veut taper 1 5 est vrai je
pensais car lycées 4 ça permettait
d'ouvrir et mais en fait rien du toit
enfin c'est pas forcément une autre ici
sans fin vous aussi
bon lors des video 8 le voit thème pour
mais
par contre s'ils trouvent ces je pensais
avant dans laquelle six dames 1
et en plus qui et c'est vrai que tu te
dis que c'est dommage tu pouvais cinq
mois je suis ton juste au dessus est-ce
que tu à autre chose et clément
est ce que roy ces mots
we hate en france et de
ses katas padam indirecte
mais en fait c'est con tu vas quand même
claqué foulée 6 d'avant pour attaquer la
paix par élimination tu vas tu vas
l'avoir abaissée effet en fait non en
plus tu vires la dame de ces trajets
pour aller te fait roi ouais c'est plus
d'un bassin avec machin là et c'est
vraiment très logique en fait
qui même pas si on va pouvoir faire une
vidéo express et l'on en fait la vidéo
express ce sera cinq minutes et puis la
plus longue ce sera 15 maria rien à dire
en fait les défenseurs 32ème minute
bon 3 bien et tout cas hier pour la plus
longue mais
voilà juste à dire sortie de la prépa
foin f1 foot il a sous-estimé tourage
prend enfin les jouets s'y
met aussi avec eux on en avait parlé
avant moi j'avais dit avant les
bookmakers qui mettait dépôt à 16 contre
moi je n'étais pas dans les favoris
favori contre un deux contre un les 16
contre 1 ça me paraissait
il peut faire en fait oui oui mon cher
s'est passé ce contrat là il peut il l'a
déjà fait donc il peut vraiment
mais hors prépa ferroudja il n'a pas
vraiment été impressionnant jusqu'à
maintenant puisque compte radjabov enfin
il est bien sorti deux fois contre à
jabba fait rapporté deux fois il était
proche de perdre et les sorties
excellemment bien contre naka il n'a pas
gagné donc en fait il a toujours été
hélas aujourd'hui il saura
normale et ouais
dépôt il commence à réfléchir maintenant
c'est important d'être précis
moi j'aimais sa gestion en fait on peut
pas dire grand chose elle est excellente
un défaut l'élan et la oumma n'en faut
et bien d'autres
une fois qu'on l'a vu c'est simple c'est
souvent comme ça
après oui donc
bastien jeter un oeil à
un côté montfa mais non il faut et six
dames 1 c'est tellement logique fin ray
après nous maintenant qu'on l'a vu c'est
vraiment logique mais je pense que même
en partie sa part est éliminations ont
pressé avec l'autre coup c'est qu'ils
essaient de vêtements pour couvrir la
quasi
ok madame partir là bas avait racheté à
trous g4 selon ce qui se passe
il va bien au pire je mettrais pioncer
devancé trois cimes attaque ex fc sète
ou quoi et je tiens bien
et moins fort mais ça a quand même bien
et tu peux brancher sur 110 ans qui est
pas pourquoi je me prends la tête
le niveau de fierro et padma moi je le
devrais après
un non mais là il n'a pas besoin de
cette partie or pour l'instant elle pas
encore fini
prenant dans l'ensemble bons joueurs
et faux produits cast jeunes non puis
oui effectivement il s'est déjà qualifié
mme anodina enfin je ne sais tu reste
perfectible à cet âge-là
il a déjà dépassé les 2008 un fauve et 6
passes
est vraiment le meilleur coût clarens et
la tre
et d'amd cette ford à melun c'est quand
même pas le même niveau en phase sur ces
tournois avant mais c'est ça rien à voir
avec
le bémol que je mettais à l'époque
mais même par rapport à la phase aller
des candidats farfelus ou candidats
précédents avec le co vident et où il
jouait pas du tout assez voilà les mac
un bon nombre global m'enfin je rappelle
la partie qui avait gagné maxime contre
digne à médine qui était ko oui mais
j'aurai un cadeau
bongha où il avait raté un truc qui est
un ratage mais bon je trouve que tu veux
pas mal être l'avait en a beaucoup qui
fin ou en gallo alex et genk au machin
là pour le moment ali riza et la
rencontre et enfin il ya eu zéro plots
en face un an mais le truc c'est que ça
joue beaucoup ce soir en face lâche que
aux autres en fait ce ding n'ont ni
favori quoi mais il était vraiment pas
dans son état enfin je sais pas où ils
seront toutefois en fait tâche sur les
styles mais nombre y voilà caruana
fidèle à lui même c'est vrai que c'est
un faux témoin gao
a pris sa retraite après le temps 1 il a
fait son retour un petit peu mais
[Musique]
hélas oui t'as pas vraiment
radjabov qui attention la main très très
solide tu le vois pas comme ça rajab
afin
d'en face mais
là sur les parties quand tu as les
quatre partenaires sont réglés quatre
mecs ont vraiment bien joué en face à
que rapporte qui à un moment donné un
peu baissé mais bon ça arrive et une
erreur mais sinon même à l'autre soit
avec eric était quand même bien fra 2e
phase de geri
renvoyait tout
un cadeau pas le grand gris juke
c'est un joueur quoi donc ouais je sais
pas ça serait comme ça c'est toujours
dur
ouais c'est jusqu'à la voix est là la
seule comparaison c'est comme tu avec
ding qui était vraiment pas bien du coup
ça fait une grosse différence entre un
mec et femmes ouvriers et qui fait
n'importe quoi forcément à toi
il n'a pas fait - capelli perdu 4 et
gagner juste contre caruana alors est ce
la veut d'être toujours belle défense il
perdait très sourd je crois digue
tendance à mettre
leurs cordes sans parti sans défaite
mais après bon là je sais pas quel bing
en a cette fois la radio moi je me suis
à steam peut-être moi j'étais un peu
déçu de ses trois premières rondes la
haine contre caruana il sort à lens
quand même pas mal je sais pas
en soi moi je le voudrais que nos
favoris de ce tournoi
je dois dire qu'il n'a pas joué contre
l'élite depuis
je pense à tes infos c'était la phase
retour des candidats ça faisait un an et
d'histoire du décalage horaire il arrive
la veille quasiment du
chili pas forcément dans les meilleures
conditions peut-être que oui
je suis hostile peut-être ce qui peut
faire en fait
dur à dire
combien la france roubaix 6 mais en fait
c'est juste que tu veux quand tu vas
faire damien tu va taper sur re5 tout
bêtement bah en fait mon lit en fait tu
t'attaques la dame des huit
ans fait en vingt quatre heures comme ça
la dame dit qu'est ce qu'elle veut faire
si tu peux celle amenant ses 3es les
maths et les blancs
et outre attaqué des deux dames c'est
cette attaque ces deux italiens qu'à
tours donc une bonne chose donc doublé 6
1 et partant de ce constat là tu es vite
ça en plus concrètement tu attaques
l'adama lacs d'eau qui a cédé 7 ou 8 tu
vas 8 tu te prends un truc bête et
méchant cet emprunt est petit il faut
prendre un progressiste prix de pièces
contre une tour matériellement en bas tu
gagnes entend lever le blocage tu en
veux tu as dame qui ont des papiers gras
scutum 17
et battu ramène ta dam maintenant en e1
donc tu t'en lèvres de tous les
histoires de vis-à-vis avec le fos est
en phase ou de tourbe et 8 il ya être
cloué ton super six et attaque le 5 dur
à défendre s'est enlevé les problèmes
tadam tu vas pouvoir peut-être faire ton
fameux c4 qui va partir
et puis voilà tous les problèmes
arrivent quand même curieux 50,23 c'est
pas juste le physiquement l'option c'est
que du coup tu as accès à la grande
diagonale à la dame tu mets le fou qui
va revenir en d4
même sur un peu comme le 4 ici peut-être
et tu crées des clous âge et donc
l'absence de ce plan à 1,5 c double pour
la fin tu perds un pion déjà ben voilà
en plus tu perds le contrôle de ces
fameuses pièces d'or et
voilà tous les problèmes conjugaux sous
les 6 évidemment oui il est très facile
ce que tu te replaces pour attaquer un
cinq et huit ans relève du vis-à-vis
donc oui c'est bien la partie elle est
déjà finie mais à la durée
les cinq coups en fait en la théorie oui
région qui a pas vraiment une partie
bah tant pis enfin bon il a raté sa part
raté sa partie
où le décor derrière bord rien surtout
de lui mettre des bus
s'est envoyé caméra dans le sens on
pouvait voir le reste de la pièce qui a
prise en main bel endroit où il joue et
srx les caméras les voit pas alors après
dans les articles et photos on peut un
peu
et en plus après fou b6 y réfléchit
encore dix minutes on y revient toujours
mais ça c'est le signe de quelqu'un qui
a qui a tout raté il est vraiment passé
à côté de sa partie il a juste raté la
partie en fait les couacs rénova et un
peu abattu battu cherche qu'est-ce que
je peux faire ou pas
c'est foutu tu y es foutu et ouais
enfin alors viens de regarder un but de
plaire même des sacs à main
orbitz pasqua va juste vous prend d'âme
quand tu prends et puis il vous est très
dense un devoir quand
il pas que
s'attaquent les pièces
donc ça de moi il faut bien la cam ouais
ça a été joué et femmes ok bon alors
encore faut-il qu'ils voient la main
mais
on imagine qu'il a fait mais si c'est
pour ça
c'est évident à
thème faut
abandonner pour faire la fête quand ça
joue bien comme ça et c'est précis en
fait c'est impressionnant c'est tout
est-ce que l'abandon et déjà un coup là
je pense que oui à partir de dames
meurthe et dans le règne qui est
peut-être eu un ou deux coups de plus
que tu as encore rien de moins mais tu
t'approches du règne d'abandon là tu as
déjà un ipad
déjà bouffé en faire deux rois
mages pour abandonner là déjà enfin je
pourrais jugement ou de fou comme ça
tempo mais ouais ou abandonné fin bref
mais est déjà dans la mentalité de j'ai
abandonné je fais juste un coup pour ne
pas incarner g4 sais rien moi tu vois
voisard beau coup pour coup
ph 3 6 devant m6 et merci enfin il a
abandonné en fait
mais oui c'est déjà avant mon possible
et ça juste pour dire en fait la partie
sur 25 coups mais comme il a envoyé 19e
un coup de théorie fin cette partie
d'âge de 34 coups tu as perdu c'est très
malin c'est plus le rush de nos partis à
nous quoi
partie raté
fait
très peur moi de vue des parties
golfeurs confirmés quant au sco n'est
pas superman en version hasard connais
j'ai pas envie d'en
bas c'est le pire scénario possible en
vue d'avoir une partie est de perdre
parce que votre avait joué que moi je ne
vous trompe plus tard et caisses à sa
note voilà le truc mieux jouer que toi
rien c'est un dépôt avoir bien joué peut
pas dire qu'il ait planté dans
l'ouverture en
scène des bouquets déçu repli qui a
répondu bien
ça dégoûtant mais
ça dégoûte il dégoûte
un peu qui a vraiment fait une partie
extraordinaire parce qu'en fait les
lignes soit disant mieux de leur dis je
c'est marrant les a pénalisés du coup et
peut-être qu'en fait ça donne des 0 0 à
la fin du récit de tout ton truc et
c'est peut-être pas point que personne
c'est que parce qu'on pratique ce genre
de truc est très dur
à juger ça
ah
bah oui venus échanger dame
a reculé bat attaque plus donc
je vois pas trop les chicken
run ça va tu dis france 5
qu il soit 1 me de the do da soit ils
échangent les dames il est peut-être
faire
un complexe complexe c'est la soupe à la
grimace côté français on va quand même
rester sur ali reza pour la fin de la
partie surtout que les autres partis ils
semblent rien se passer de décisif 1 à
l'heure actuelle pas encore de ravoir
ding
a des raisons qui a enlevé la chine
reste
il n'a pas vu grand chose de la partie
alireza
que s'ils perdent c'est fini tôt alors
non loin de là c'est un tournoi qui se
joue en 14 parties c'est pas
éliminatoire une défaite après ça ne
l'est pas en bonne posture évidemment
parce que nés pour son adversaire du
jour était déjà dans le coup et déjà un
petit peu de retard par rapport à lui
est là en le battant en était à servir
ex
lviv quoi donc il va y avoir il y avait
un nid pour un des carmes n'ya point et
demi
avec nespouls gagne ça se fait pas comme
ça quoi mais eux
sidya l'iresa ne craque pas reprendre
son cours normal à avoir gagné une
partie revient 50% le tournant encore
très long 14 parties assez cru la 4e et
ready
c'est pas fini mais évidemment c'est
passé en rêvait
[Musique]
tu vois je te fous tu prends un but dès
la première minute
j'ai même de la
taper un match aller 1 0 au match retour
de john 9,0
pas trop envie de ça quoi non mais après
ça fait un certain temps s'ils gagnent
il va avoir les blancs demain ils jouent
contre qui
regardez s'ils gagnent qui répond tout
de suite avec les blancs demain comme
l'avait fait n'a qu'a finalement on dit
ailleurs dans le monde main
d'hilton 12 heures mais il a besoin de
gagner vite une partie quoi
pour reprendre pour prendre part prendre
après tout je suis aussi toujours
l'espoir que peut-être dépôts va perdre
une partie un jour il faut si tu aimes
tu reviens voilà les blancs comptent
duda donc oui il a clairement une chance
un
bâtiment enchaîné les plans duda et les
blanchir août les blancs caruana faudra
faire une mission de quoi
as tu finis par 50% la phase aller tu
vois après
et puis on verra
à noter que mes potes ap les deux
favoris belle perf oui là c'est vrai
qu'il a tapé ding est il en passe de
taper firoud c'est vrai qu'il fait mal
et de joker la whey n'est peau qui est
vraiment là
montré un niveau de jeu quand même très
élevé sur cette phase aller pour le
moment
ça se voyait tellement qu'ils étendent
cru que ça allait mal se passer
fugue 12 minutes me suis finalement
qu'il aurait été mal autant à ben alaoui
et les balles hautes
malheureusement pas que
je l'adoré les blancs avec 12 minutes
peut-être eh bien pas
là paf enfin bref tout à fait c'est ça
cette partie dans le mauvais
opérations à partir de ce moment là
il va tomber en or mais n'en faites pas
à huy
un meilleur coup pop d'abandonner
pas mal d'en donner
avis de plus aux souffrances
j'ai perdu j'ai perdu je passe à autre
chose
elle fera battouta demain pas facile
mais faisable
c'est pas le plus solide tout
d'après duda en plus il joue des
instants qui s'est mis à la nage dorff
donc fillon voit bien analysé du coup tu
peux avoir des idées embête un peu tu
tiens je me plante et couleurs inversées
ça m'a l'air plus
une petrov
major est très forte je pense qu'il y
est mais tu peux prendre des trucs comme
aujourd'hui tu perds 25 ans que tu te
trompes petrov ses robustes
suis trompé au pire tu es moins bien
mais tu
turmel
ne contienne contre 22e mais bon là ça
change rien fait l'annoncé en change
plus rien aux 26e par donc le temps
change plus rien parce que
les jeux sont déjà faits a pas moins de
d'une gaffe incroyable
[Musique]
tous
juste ça retient ses trois
terminaux
fait mal psychologiquement je pense est
parti
au nom de leur trophée jamais plaisir là
ouais surclassé surclassé sur la partie
belle jambe il est passé au travers
ouais
bah se rendre malade sait rebondir
demain à d'autres affaires
perdre comme ça c'est toujours un
homo hésité un moment hyper vite
il perd pas 22 heures après avoir vu
huit heures et finalement
pas non plus un match nul
au malawi il a juste raté de tous les
partis
pendant 1h30 quand cette heure ouais
c'est vrai aussi un
c'est dur le haut niveau
des radios streamées
exigences
il vient vous très très bon les eaux
sont très bons aussi
et que bombe
en quelque sorte ça rappelle un peu le
sien de la partie de maxime contrat
porte
vous allez y aurait trois coup pareil en
fait passer différents dans le temps de
deux jeux etc mais c'est un peu la même
impression afin de la partie fait c'est
juste que tu as même pas joué en fait
j'ai fait surclasser t'as même pas jouer
et maxime avait bien joué le lendemain
les faits il ya nice bien
puisque la petite de jeudi des
recompositions oui c'est un genre
d'attaqué alireza quand même
et c'est que de bonnes preuves qui prend
juste à
tomber vite arthurienne le fou
hein t'as pas plus d'attaquants que ça
le problème c'est que terra d'owerri
colonnes tous écoulement vers son bien
bloquer ces cinq qui va t'arriver dessus
date empruntis peut-être un moment
atteint
4,5 alliage 5
tout va vraiment
en france et de se prendre la tour voilà
à blaye enfin n'oubliez pas tout fait
alors dit la gym je suis en plus un pas
de piège vous préserver il faut voir ça
pas facile
ça sympa durée des plans plus reste plus
que six minutes maintenant
sur ans pas que ce soit louable en fait
même là c'est là c'est devenu trop
facile depuis fou mais ici je pensais
plus louable à pardonner et de le
fouiller
difficile
mais du coup wayne et beau qui se fait
vraiment bien pour le temps 20
à 30 plus de
way
de blanc de noir
on sera peut-être une petite pause après
la fin de cette partie française et on
n'en ferait entre puis avant de faire le
résumé exclure de recul on sac
15h18 30 way entre 18 30 19 heures on
aura le temps de faire à cinq minutes de
pause sans de récup et un tout petit peu
on n'a pas une petite pub à mettre la
musique à fond non non mais qu'on adore
relever des gammes ses taux mais n'est
qu'un oui mais oui on travaille quand
vous avez des tambours
vraiment dégueulasse
on a eu 30 foyer noir une défaite et pas
qu'à taiwan 20-26 gagne contre utah
demain en soit ça peut aller sais pas où
je veux savoir et avoir gagné demain
vers gaza
duda c'est pas non plus le péno du
siècle peut le battre mais on peut ne
pas le bateau doit battre cet accord
le grand darwin c'est plutôt qu'autre
chose foutu en fait la position
quand tu vois la pendule réfléchi
il se trouve un miracle mais qui n'est
pas là année 1 80
juste un petit tour à et sur les autres
positions
ouais
bon on veut pas seulement on verra bien
ce
rapport n'a
caricature même position qu'à d'autres
un peu précis peut-être
mois il a l'air de ce yacht est un peu
ça peut être une partie intéressante et
changer les dames
a priori ça devrait faire une
structure pour i chez les noirs on est
beaucoup d'activités pour rien on voit
qu'elle des champions en leroy h un
écrêtement aubois rapport aux renards
j'imagine la quitter et qu'on pense
peut-être nul partout mais on accable
pas se tromper on va
presser bien si tout allait pourtant
j'ai envie de dire allez a fait tomber 8
île séparée avec 3,8 à la pendule il
part quand même
ça c'est quelqu'un qui veut abandonner
avec trois buts à la pendule tu te
barres mobiles vont pas loin
serez vous au magnus je pense pas qu'il
refusera match retour contre nez pour en
vue avec la facilité avec laquelle il a
gagné le premier
bike est ce que ça vient de refuser mais
et grand livre bons amis français né peu
après je dirais oui c'est une interview
il a dit ça s'engage rien
non non je le vois pas
manu soi même y aller sans préparer
non mais bon coup
pour coup ces prépas est importante en
inde s'il a quand même bien tenu quand
il avait neuf
matches
et s'ils refusent très violent entre le
premier deuxièmement il sera plus
champion du monde s'y refuse et je
reçois pas bien
je pense que le vainqueur des candidats
doit être champion
il a joué x 5 quasi tempo
patentés qui s'écartent ici
façon il va cliquer un
c3 tranquille
nippon il en a absolument rien à [ __ ]
europe
en vidéo ici avec bienne les candidats
et que la carte ne vient pas pourquoi ce
serait pas alors je comprends que en
termes d'audience la fille d'entendre un
match et j'ai 10 ans 75 confie charles
est pas venu on appelle des grottes pas
à temps au fait tu veux que le fils des
candidats que tu as déjà battu
d'ailleurs mais tu vas rejoint conclut
pas aux champions du monde
non mais tu même si tu refuses le match
ça bizarre en fait par fo
en fait je suis pas contre le fait
d'arrêter ce match championnat du monde
mais faut proposer une alternative c'est
juste pour dire je ne joue pas je ne
joue pas mais ne par un toi si tu dis je
ne joue pas mais si c'était tel format
je jouerai - t'offre une alternative de
quelque chose d'intéressant mais c'est
juste pour dire
en mai après leur bond aux rameurs frage
problème qu'est ce que faire la place
fin même époque et on a pris le relais
de l'inviter ton badin invités vont tuer
le match l'afflux ambition d'être
champion enfin c'est pas ça va un peu à
l'encontre l'histoire des échecs oui
mais bon non mais a pris la noire n'est
fait non non bien sûr bien sûr mais bon
sat 1 devraient par une sanction directe
que ce qu'on aurait pas de sanctionner
je fais ce que tu veux mais sega lâche
pas très grande chez sourds
l'aï vu que je partage son bien du monde
et que du coup nous ressert la donner
ouais bah voilà n'a pas dit qu'à la
place d'un mec qui motive c'est ça le
truc idiot tu te retires un peu du
circuit professionnel
c'est lui qui a parlé de ça en interview
c'est pas nous qui il a dit que en gros
c'était fatigant soit le champion du
monde pourrait plein de temps plein
d'énergie la préparation tout ça qui va
faire un peu autre chose et que là il a
un peu fait le tour et d'un peu de tout
le monde et que en gros à moi je sois
l'iresa qui gagne un tirage intéressant
avec une régénération ils soient pas
rejoindre un match
c'est caronna qui se présente dans le
dernier match il a pas battus file
abattu on départage messina les douze
parties longues c'est bien je vois pas
pourquoi
n'en majijuana il était assis pour l
aude lui a pas si longtemps mais là il a
une petite phase difficile avec le co
vide ou quoi mais gérard van gogh vide
elle a 20 points 20 points de retard
qu'il n'est pas inédite est pas si
distant et que ce à quoi
voit la faune ses mains c'était juste
des paroles aux interviews et que pèsera
le pour et le contre
et donc juste dit dan au cas où cette
éventualité j'aimerais enfin ce qui est
prévu c'est que le vainqueur des creux
d'avant
match
un quart des candidats qui pour moi
d'oise est un champion du monde de fait
atout gagnant pour les blancs au moins
c'est facile
bref ces trois sets locaux qui
ont alors dit propose un tour prend m6
est compliqué mais pourquoi pas aidé
c'est que vous preniez dame est fait
une double attaque
avec mata suivre
à peut-être être
vraiment important surtout ces trois
tranquille où
il faisait froid et qu'il prend des cinq
à regarder
on a regardé en
effet décidé encore un autre
va bien un mot
tout gagné en fait
je crois qu'il faut d'abord trouver
autant à 15 ans il avait la tresse quoi
jouer
alors c'est faisable mais en fait il va
voir des décisions à prendre quand même
dans les coups qu'ils jouent
il sait même pas pourquoi il joue en
phase 1 1 mais bon faut quand même finir
la partie à
des fois quand et comme ça que tu
attends juste que l'autre abandonne tu
joues plus en fait sajjad et coups de
mer donc rester concentrés dans ces cas
là c'est sûr ouais
mais là j'y crois fort à la victoire
donné peu quand même
c'est là aussi qu'on voit la force de
magnus par rapport aux autres c'est que
là on voit un dépôt dans ce tournoi dont
quand il joua au max qui fait mal à tout
le monde
même pas du tout mais magnus il a aussi
reçu obtenir des positions une épaule
jouer moins bien ce que c'est a dit
rezaï n'a pas réussi à faire ici au
contraire il a joué sur le jeu fort de
dépôt et c'est aussi ça qui paye
aujourd'hui
elle avait une minute 11 contre 1h11
ciné peau d'âne en un ace qui pourrait
gagner a tué hier par rapport au temps
ah oui mais il veut les faire des coups
oui bien des fois ils étaient partis
là-dessus internet vers 80 coups ont pu
l'être on n'y a pas le pré move mais ça
va enfin donc c'est pas un exploit de
faire 10
m us et que vers des coûts difficile à
chaud et froid
on demande une stent
nouvelle qui jouent comme stent houston
tu préférais de vlad jeu n'a pas encore
vu dans le chatt travail la journée
enfin travail soit disant sur l'a 10 ans
et
a déposé un peu l'antidote contre firoud
déjà en fait les meilleurs dans tous les
secteurs de jeu
paloffis rouge à karlsson ça ne
peut-être pas très envie encore qu'elle
avait pour l'instant que leurs notes aux
mines beaucoup d'affrontements
à quand remonte le temps des fêtes de
fiona 1 contre maxime au grand jeu tour
bucarest donc a pas si longtemps mais
c'était un temps de préparation ça jouer
vraiment
pas pareil
déjà ça vous laisse entrer pas du tout
on voit que c'est le gros point voire
d'alireza c'est un peu comme caruana
vaut quoi on a enlevé le service le debt
le point prince a voulu de servir à 200
kilomètres/heure ils font un service
cuillère donc ça change
beaucoup
ne vous a pas dit qu il faut que tu vois
un firmament des plantes est moins fort
en philo il très très précoce est très
très fort
a passé 2008 ils n'ont pas été nombreux
dans l'histoire est à 10,9 en personne
donc voilà ma principauté bon mix est
tout même à ce jeu c'est pas un truc
comme ça
un dépôt qui contemple sa bonne position
professionnel
discrètement je pense même si tu prenais
le fou à 5 ce n'est pas si clair en fait
même si le supprimer quoi tu le
mix objet
même là un tour point m6 tf1 oui autres
n'ont matériellement ce à quoi yaakov
donc plus
juste la pression des rentes à regarder
mais en fait en soi ce n'est qu'un pion
qu
il est plus obligé de noter les courir
et la quand on a moins de 5 minutes et
qu'il n'y a pas de rajoute temps on
n'est plus obligé de noter on est là
quand même noté parce que il veut avoir
un sourire à sa joie
si la sof ce serait un des plus grands
exploits des francs miracle de
l'histoire des candidats
ils gagnent pas 5 secondes par coup dans
la ja et
ça à l'ancienne quoi
faire c'est une question de se poser vaz
pourquoi vu qu'il faut une cadence aussi
longue pour que les joueurs puissent
jouer leur meilleur qualité de jeu
pourquoi pas 10 heures ouais non mais
pourquoi pas donner 30 secondes par coup
là se pose est réellement la question
genre mais nous étions tellement de
choses pour que le niveau de jeu soit au
et dire que j'ai pas de bliss et pas de
toit de manque de temps quoi il n'en est
pas du coup pourquoi pas leur donner 30
secondes par coup pour être sûr qu'ils
aient pas d'eux ait note trop sévère il
sert et que la question se pose pourquoi
pas dans les cinq ans fera
aussi majeur
qui t'a donné beaucoup au moins aller
vraiment à fond et au bout dans le
délire plate se poser la question en
live à ce que toi tu en penses tu aurais
eu ce que tu aurais donné 30 secondes
par coup de rage ou en plus
non
déjà bien assez long comme ça mais c'est
vrai que c'est ça ton argument pour
faire des petits très lente je délire
encore plus loin
ce que la canton quand on réfléchit à
voix comme souvent c'est avait un peu
moins de temps là bas
c'est pas vrai sur toutes les parties
mais là cette partie c'est un nouvel
exemple un peu de en fait là bas mais si
les rougeurs d'être radjabov c'était
aussi ça 13
9 fois sur 10 je dirais presse je vous
presse toujours le coup tu veux un
problème alors des fois non
pas simple à griller par an cette partie
je sais juste qu'il veut pas le punch
gâcher ne pas gâcher on va faire un
petit tour des stades
ding apparemment il s'est retrouvé
le roi le roi va arriver avant version
wii
est donc ça doit être nul d'orage pour
ding
un ak contre rapport
ok bon je sais pas quel point issue mais
une petite phase d agrafes scénario - il
va falloir travailler
alors des vannes 0 0
il ya une tour qui a disparu de pfk ce
g5 et les partis là bas
on en aura dof perdra pas ça
on n'y est pas mauvais
y'a pas de raison qui n'importe quoi on
se dirige vers un nul chez uta radjabov
présent se dirige vers une défaite pour
ali reza et 3 nuls 1 quand même sur les
trois autres partis
peut-être que d'un cas qui peut être la
terre mais dans ce genre de situation il
est généralement très solide
et trouve les défenses
on va retourner sur la position à ben
ali reza après ce coup d'un réussi ce
coup de trafalgar
alireza repris près pas non non mais bon
aloi de perdre en milieu de jeu aussi un
dans celui qui a fait d'après par an ce
qui est des trois qui est des cinq
classes qui vient annoncer qu'ils
cliquent au moins on n'attend pas une
demi-heure parcours
s'est mis à bien joué la jr east a
déclaré chip le way non mais sa
meilleure séquence de coûts depuis
depuis le début de la partie c'est quand
il a arrêté de réfléchir oui
mais ce qui est marrant c'est qu'il est
peut-être les pharaons après il manquait
le le caraïbe et cinq sur les dames
c'est simple et a fait sans réfléchir à
l'anti sûr ils avaient de bons coups
tout en réfléchissant en fait il a
manqué un coup plus loin le bon si tu
joues au hasard pas de calais b 5e
gagnant
après la seule micro difficulté avec sa
tournée peau c'est qu'il reste dix
minutes une minute pardon vous enfants
regagnent pas il va faire une gaffe est
balayé
[Musique]
c'est là la seule couilles est qui peut
et qui peut lui arriver en fait on va
arriver à jouer les bons coups tout seul
le
fatah c'est un peu comme une blessure
dans un maillot témoin faut des mecs qui
déjoue complètement avec ce précieux
acquis et sur une jambe
s'ils vont aller j'en vois la balle et
peut plus cliquez donc tu te fais que
des coups gagnants et tu sais plus faim
tu te perds
tu par flemme à la place d'un dépôt
cela vous échappe
interview gâcher munitions vous que de
5000 sako sanogo d'y
aller 1 et pourquoi pas fab
donc absolument tout games ea bon c'est
que même quand cammalleri monde et 5,6
d'échangés encore t'es cette fourchette
en même temps certaines mentale et or
qui sont mal placés
non mais j'ai déjà un truc genre
floirac
j'ai pas et tout d'un coup à
pas de chance
ouais ouais on est là à quoi agence à
rien
st
et c'est pour nettoyage 0 coup gagnant 1
et pontus a eu la bonne attitude bref le
chien ouais
10 dont le tchad j'y crois
il ya une petite chance ou net
c'est quoi c'est une chance sur mille
je mettrais quoi
un ou deux pourcent 1% que
c'est beaucoup quand même en vrai
par rapport à la position de merde qu'il
a
me pour 100 e
chez paddy qui met 2 7% selon l'idh à 0
je faisais beaucoup c'est bien payé il
soit le pen comme disent les anglais
non c'est très bien payé
moi
que faire à part attendre
important c'est beaucoup en fait
vous rendez pas compte
on sait plus trop quoi vous dit en fait
on est prêt il se faire une petite pause
on la fin de la partie on s'était dit ça
va arriver fia pour fatma en fait non on
la fera quand même
la lie à fiat
ça a l'air pas mal hein s'amuse à google
pour prendre
rendez-vous qui échangent un cavalier et
offensive
est la pire au delà je vous des bons
coups quand il a pu le temps charmant
ouais mais le problème c'est que
l'étendue des dégâts
ça risque de ne pas suffire mais pas
besoin de beaucoup mieux jouer
à wii
fait il ya peut-être 1h59 de trop
problème c'est qu'elle prend d ici
cinq
parties niveau c'est terrible 13 30
secondes est arrivé de rêver de terminer
d'échiquier bout d'un moment ça le
dérangeait pas pour cela d'ailleurs
partie il partit pour un cahier avec 35
secondes pour sept coups mais si
terrible en fait de partir que vous avez
déjà rendez vous il en a rien à [ __ ]
de rien en fait
vous allez tourner
j'ai rarement vu ça en fait
pour tf1 tempo
voir s'il faut prendre et de et
n'importe quoi dames quatre
voix tandis que l'esa en p2 comme un
conte ce cavalier
là bas il sortira jamais embêté
ouais c'est terrible
c'est assez terrible
l'infection à partie ça fait mal hein
c'était arrivé en fait
rien
fait d' une grimace mme kébé 2
aucun respect vrai
mais on s'en fout c'est normal je trouve
ça irrespectueux il est tellement
dominante
autour des fins savoir le troupeau
logique un rappel la toile 4 n'est pas
prenable simplement parce que si ce
n'est plus protégé de claude chossat qui
a tourné attaqué bon peut justement mais
voilà après évidemment vous promet
d'autres un coût mais pourquoi c'est pas
une autre case noire pour ce qui est des
deux peut rien faire on pille on prend
trois à le prendre un jour ce matin
en douceur et
collation
il est balèze n'est pour eux que si je
te rassure il est très à l'aise
il est extrêmement à l'aise beaucoup
trop à l'aise
au tour des landes j'aurais fait un
homme de cette trempe faire gaffe yadan
17 il ya plus de courage
il faudra trouver autre chose genre ça
ça va bien ça c'est un autre courage
mais attention - il réduit au fronton
alors à temps il a joué tordez f1 ali
reza qui a répondu du tac au tac tours 8
justement pour des clous et un de la
colonne f donc attaquer la tour qui va
donc j'ai
eu quatre départs avec notamment 24
ali reza qui tangue encore plus 24
secondes pour cinq coups bon allez là
plus de coups du tout d'un mieux
qu'attendu c'est un contreur ab 700 lève
pour bessette
f5 attaque la tour
haha
j'adore les grimaces table chaque
critique droite en page 7 canaux
sa salle apprend même
genre la petite tête qui aurait dit oui
bon tu tombes on achète déjà là c'est
sûr qu'il a vu oui
les raisins aussi en fait
mais je voudrais tous vous voit-on
proche de sa gagne ou
je viens voir absolument jusqu'au
jeudi 7 secondes pour ali reza qui va
s'incliner sous nos yeux
pas hyper fait plus d'un pardessus obama
il a le droit de jouer un bon moi je
trouve ça pas de mondiaux à ce stade
personne phandu maximale
randonnée
peuvent et slaves
[Musique]
bon ben moi je fonce alors c'est que
quand tu abandonnes pâques mais à l'otan
quoi tu laisse la possibilité à l'autre
de ce lever de faire de la merde il a
envie ceux-ci toi qui l'a laissé faire
si je n'étais pas contente avait
abandonné en fait c'est comme les mecs
quand j'aime attendre un switch com qui
avant même pas je l'attends humide 30
ouais bah je ne m'en fait enfin c'est
toi qui es matin je fais ce que je veux
un sac abandonné en fait non là tu te
sert du café faux
chacun fait ce qu'il veut mais la sueur
ça à faire plutôt pour
pour les peaux
donc après ça en fera une petite pause
on vous fera le récap de la partie 1
moi je kiffe n'est pas aux moyens albi
d'un
petit pour les qui dépasse et oui c'est
le bit qui a fait la diff
après les beats sont pacifiques mais
comme l'a dit plate mais le problème
c'est que c'est fear ucia qui a cherché
à faire des nouveautés peut-être que oui
c'est juste une petite nuit dans la
neige d'enfants fait de base
il s'en foutait complètement peut-être
le fauteuil at
il attaqué le bide
après ça va être quand même marrant la
saison échiquéenne parce que le prochain
tour ou non avec un réel enjeu sera en
mars 2023 si ça changera du monde on va
prendre on voit les a complètement
écoeuré
bâle attaquera g8 frère
et cavaliers preuve cinq
balles et 13 secondes frérot
il va perdre autant en demande souvent
si on peut perdre autant ou pas non ils
jouent encore floues f6
va le mat il l'a déjà bien d'un mal
cette
sarah perdre autant
presque
abandon d'alireza fille rouge à qui
s'incline
face à un époux mis à chier impérial
dans cette partie très vite voire un
dépôt
partie parfaite
voit les deux joueurs qui discutent à un
petit peu ouais ouais je sais pas rien
vu frère de la partie c'est pas grave ça
arrive à tout le monde tu reviendras
plus fort dans deux ans
faut peut-être que tu prennes un peu de
poids
moi j'étais prêt à faire nuit si tu
voulais frérot mais c'est toi qui m'a
cherchée
tu fais du hem je fais du xl
ça dégage
celle
offrant un vaste ayem et
fait des nuls comme nous et je te le
faire mais quoi
j'ai un message de dépôt qui me dit
frérot garde-moi deux ou dix tailles
double xl un blanc un noir se plaît
t'inquiète pas je garde ça pour toi et
oui ça fait ses emplettes côté néo peau
c'est régulier chez cramique on va là je
crois que ça aurait pu que les du tout
c'est la 4 par quatrième parti de merde
après
après l'ouverture j'exagère un peu mais
c'est vrai que c'est la quatrième partie
où il est un peu en dessous il ya
peut-être des heures dans la prépa après
est-ce que cramique c'était le bon choix
est ce que est ce qu'il est au niveau
encore aujourd'hui on se posera ses
questions là la fin du tournoi semble un
peu tôt
j'ai pas mal à la dynamique s'est pas
exposé ensemble
bon alors c'est tout pareil nov
est ce que c'est les bons choix est ce
que est ce qu'ils ont ils ont vraiment
focus sur les ouvertures ça se voit ça a
été réussie est ce que est ce qu'il a
ici là on a trop fait avant et il arrive
un peu en méforme en milieu de jeu on
sait pas c'est encore trop pour tirer
des conclusions n'est qu'à quatre
parties peut-être que sa défaite va lui
faire du bien et va le
[Musique]
lui enlever une pression qui sait
peut-être mise à mal de trucs on peut
pas lui reprocher
la question que j'avais c'est le côté
pratique
comme il n'avait pas joué quasiment pas
du tout entre sa qualif aux grands
suisse et l'a juste fait un petit tour à
bucarest donc en fait il n'a pas un côté
pratique il a dû faire des parties
d'entraînement tout ça ne t'a pas le
stress des tournois des caméras du puits
qui te regarde comment tu t'es poindron
jeu compagnie et
ça c'était mon interrogation perso pas
de là dessus
mais en tout cas on peut pas dire qu'il
ait manqué de travail en votant
d'ouverture non mais parfois beaucoup de
travail ça faisait ça
c'est tout le travail sert jamais à rien
au pire si ce qui est dit pas cette fois
ce sera quelque chose d'étrange et c'est
bien la fin pour faire un bilan
calmement
calment donc on va faire un petit on
fait un petit tour des esprits on va se
faire une petite pause avant l'avant le
récap express dingli rennes
très vite il a fait tour à 8 ça joue pas
à mes lordi d'un égal et apparemment le
roi va juste venir prendre les pions et
si c'est juste la ligne force et direct
qui fait nul donc ça va être nul un
nouveau raté pour ding rapporte contre
naka
salaire de données nul
tout va s'échanger ça va faire un nul on
peut voir que des nuls
va pas durer très longtemps à écouter on
vous laisse sur la position de ding et
nous on va se faire une petite pause et
on suivra après la partie dit que je
pense que les deux autres ont ce soldés
par deux nuls très rapide au sol et ça
va jouer encore un petit peu ici à tout
égard
voilà grimaçant les gars il sur i told
the soup of the great maïs
franchement c'est ouais c'est la
déception en discuter ya eu deux nuls à
côté comme prévu on vous avait dit il ya
eu nulle il ya eu les deux nuls qui a
été si bien sûr les deux autres partis
on était partis on vous avait dit que
c'était déjà terminée et donc il n'en
reste plus qu'une
et franchement et là ça va faire du le
c'est sûr aussi
basique mais en fait ils voient qu'ils
ne joue pas alors je ne sais pas ce
qu'il a fait comme truc avant les
précédents mais dans ta zoa tue plus
traiter flèche près comment le roi
arrive avant le roi blanc au tempo
problème pour la taz au temps frais mais
pas de chance croit ces trois français
cinq
membres aussi à cause de cette marque
c'est nul en fait alors qu'est-ce qui
l'auraient raté avant
ouest-centre avait vu
avec et c5 c'est peut-être ça la
connerie est peut-être lors didier f3
après vous calculez
tours à huit tours b
1.4 tenteront pétrole
enfin c'est mieux que ce qu'il a dans là
c'est plus que ce qu'il a eu quoi qu'il
en soit
[Musique]
bon il est temps de se faire ce petit
résumé de la partie dernière les a
maintenant enfin on a vu que les deux
autres partis étaient signées on a
compris pourquoi celle là se dirigeait
vers un nul à jouer tour b 1 alors ça
mais trois évasions il forma du colonel
4c 3% 4
je ne sais pas dans quel sens le roi ces
deux jours tout on prend 1,4 et le roi
qui avaient rebloqué espions et
on a toujours su aller on va vous faire
le résumé express the express résumé
comme nous on longe nous l'ont volé les
américains bien évidemment un concept
femme bien d'ou vient à nous et qu'on
est les premiers à faire ah voilà ça
n'existe nulle part le résumé sans
variantes
bon je crois qu'il a beaucoup qu'il faut
non mais nous c'est eux ils font des
variantes très courte et y donne d
évaluer on a remis comme dirait van où
on donne des évaluations normal mais
s'en va rallumer sans variantes
alors on fait quoi tu es noir on se met
un seul ego thérèse débat vas-y donc une
ronde numéro quatre des candidats
alireza fjrca qui est opposée avec les
pièces noires à eliane nepomniachi le
joueur russe ex challenger au titre
mondial qui envoient eux quatre ces
cinq-là sicilienne cavaliere trois des
six des quatre qui on prend des quatre
quais et prend des quatre cavaliers f6
cavale et ses 3es assises fab la nage
daf ali reza qui acceptent le combat de
rue face à un spécialiste mondial de
l'ouverture yann nepomniachi exactement
savait pas si ferroudja gervais à la
nage darfour ou l'arroseur est pas là on
à votre réponse et à six niveaux qui
joue la f3 comme carnage dans ce tournoi
a eu cinq attaques lecavalier qui part
en b3 aussi ce fou 3 fawcett on suit la
grande théorie d'amd de petit rock grand
raclée rock reposer calais b 17 et j'ai
quattro c'est parti les pions parts des
marrons b5 g5 b4 le calice et 3 doit
être sauvés on n'a pas le temps de
prendre à 6,3 attaque la dame au passage
égale chèques importants
du coup cavalli eux deux près de 8 f
quattre ouvre le jeu à 5 protège le
pount haut et envoie le pion f5 et ici
femmes la surprise ou à la chef c'est
pas une nouveauté mais presque énervante
partie des dizaines de milliers je vais
k4 mais ici sur johan djourou c4 ce qui
surprend un époux mené hachey mais il a
joué assez vite en fait un essai
politique relevant surprendre laférois
bien cache le roi de france il est comme
ça sur 1,4 le coût de la partie elle a
cassé un pour le cavalier des cinq ses
idées noires pour les bleus à des cages
sautant la case des six pour le cavalier
ou en tout cas moi j'ai de l'ambition on
secoue une époque east est pas complet
effet m6 pour l'heure les droits si on
prend si on prend et ici après une
première longue hésitation ali reza qui
a repris du cavalier des cavaliers eux
prend ici c'était aussi possible et de
coûts étaient équivalents mais ce qui
est très fort côté nepomniachi c'est
qu'il sait prime prépare on a vu ali
reza qui était très confiant à la caméra
et une épaule l'air de rien un peu dans
son style caractéristique qui cliquent
vite trois coups et qui a complètement
renverser la pression et cette pression
qui va faire mal puisqu'il va jouer
cavalier g3 avec l'idée peut-être de
prendre dans ces cas de jouer sur la
colonne des est ici c'est la deuxième
fois qu'elle réserve à réfléchir très
longtemps pour jouer foot.fr qui n'était
pas le meilleur coup un coup comme dame
c7 aurait été meilleur on y reviendra
dans l'analyse poussée fou point f1 et
là il était très surpris il a dû passer
beaucoup de temps à calculer tour des
prêts fin des dépôts qui revient
s'asseoir 30 il réfléchit 3 4 minutes
bim tourache point f1 le meilleur couple
l'ordi et toura chef un très fort
famille met la pression sur la colonne f
et sur la colonne des way cette tournée
qui est resté ici qui garde l'avantagé
face à la dame et c'est un très bon
choix on aurait pu attendre je tends
l'autre prise de la tour en cédant oui
mais le port seront bien en effet j'ai
mais on voit que c'est dur d'entrer sur
la colonne g est donc là c'est mieux
jouer les réseaux cratchit beaucoup qui
fait à trois le meilleur que la position
enfin des démonstrations sur sur
cazenove b3 pour garder la colonne a
fermé et on voit que à cause de la
présence de suez 5 c'est pas si facile
que ça d'aller chercher la casse b2 il
va jouer trois chutes alireza un coup
qui aurait pu être joué dans n'importe
quelle position entre guillemets parce
que ce roi était mal placé puis on prend
des 5 et là il fallait absolument
trouver dames c'est celle qui était le
seul coup avec une variante vraiment
compliqué en ont cinq six coups dans la
variante y avait quelque chose de très
difficile à voir il y avait des
problèmes abbas deux des six et il
fallait vraiment être précis là encore
on n'est pas là pour entrer dans le
détail il joue cavalier des six pour se
placer avec les chevaux mais le fou ne
contrôle plus la case b4 et yann qui
vient prendre ce pion bep cap et comme
tulle expliqué pendant le direct femme
c'est plus qu'un pion qui tombent ici
ouais c'est l'option b 4 votre servait
de socle pour les doigts pour la casse
ces trois pour y amener un cavalier
notamment où une dame quelque chose là
il est plus là et de deux le pion c2d
blanc un an et mobiles et venait avant
il va la présentation maintenant plus
râpeux avancer sa mère soutient pions
des et à avancer les deux pions centraux
du coup c'est un gros problème ali reza
fait tour s'est vite mais la tour sur la
colonne et l'année poids très bien joué
il a fait tout b6 le goût le plus précis
attaque la dame n'a que deux cases est
venu en 17,8 ça allait passer
tarifs 6 surcharge du phosphate sur les
deux cavaliers donc d'amener cette jouer
et dames 1 et en voilà théâtre ou b6 et
à enlever sous 2 3 maintenant le point
qui attaquait et en plus sa dame ne peut
pas se diriger vers 1,5 et c3 pour les
mater sur carte blanche maintenant il
est là en fait elle est apte à être
quasiment plus de temps ici bien je
t'aime beau et sauvage avait tombé huit
attaques le fou fou à 520 qui s'éclatent
sur le clouage attaque à nouveau un
petit peu de vous aimer bout avec plein
de choix ici la fée des cif ont
désorganisé les pièces port et sur envoi
de francs serait pas possible sans
l'aide des choses comme ça
en manque de temps à fait fou des vite
maintenant pousser 3 revient à se placer
sur la belle diagonale et celle blanc
qui ont la priorité de cette diagonale
qui est ultra importante ce que c'est la
diagonale qui donnerait le matin b2 pour
les noirs mais c'est les blancs qui ont
la priorité dessus et qui tape le roi il
a fait état de six pour essayer tout
défendre cavaliers detroit le cavalier
qui étaient reclus à une tâche défensive
qui vient attaquer le pion aux 5 à
rallier des cinq on essaye de contre
attaquer sur le fou ces trois cavaliers
f4 surtout les clous et ça joue surtout
les plus riches si on prend ces trois on
reprend et on va taper absolument
partout cavaliers prend un f4 on échange
des cavaliers tout reprend de nouveau
clouage et on commence à taper même si
les noirs non leur prêter car il est
encore protégé par la dame f6 pour
casser ce clouage et créé un petit andy
murray une petite petite muraille est là
maintenant dame de deux attaques locales
et ses 4 on va se reprendre ça me prend
d'ailleurs ce qui veut dire partie en b2
attaqué la tour il a garé sa tour en
ville a fait le tour des f1 sur quoi il
ya fait tour 8 parce qu'évidemment la
toile 4 la protée pas prenable puisque
la dame si ce n'est pour protéger toi et
te protège la dame et en plus on menace
maintenant de prendre 5 puisqu il
protège et parti que sa tour à h 4 et 5
bon ben je t'attaque la tourache 4
l'année pour a bien réfléchi et a trouvé
trois sets roy pro forcée d'un match 5
échecs crois j'ai vite quel point m 5 il
se place tout est ici pour que le maté
tour g1 et abandon pourquoi puisque
après roy et fuites ailleurs matt à
suivre après damage 6 3 cette tour g7
vous prendra prend donc une partie très
aboutie de la part de nepomniachi qui a
réussi à esquiver la préparation
d'ali reza firoud déjà remettre la
pression sur le joueur français et il
n'a pas tremblé pour conclure une partie
un petit peu décevante pour ali reza qui
continuent un peu sur les traces de ce
qu'il avait fait dans les trois
premières parties très très bon dans
l'ouverture mais un petit peu en dessous
dans le début du milieu de jeu il faudra
régler ça pour revenir dans le tournoi
et peut-être dès demain contre
jean-christophe duda avec les pièces
blanches
voilà
ça va être quand
ils sont bien ces petits régimes et
express je sais pas ce que vous en
pensez
très pédagogique je pense or voilà ces
semaines la pédagogie beaucoup plus
pédagogique que l'on
aurait envie de guillaume canet
[Rires]
guillaume canet
les ricains sont passés par là alors on
en les américains donc pas encore lancé
ces régimes est on est on est en avance
sur est en fait ce que nous ont vraiment
zéro variante vers ses deux flèches
louis peut pas prendre ces intrus
comprise et c'est ouais je sais pas le
format en fait j'avais tu le mets ta
mais j'ai pas regardé je les ai vécus
beau format web très beau forme
j'apprécie beaucoup on va en faire plus
souvent aux abats oui c'est plus
meilleure forme à
tort est de faire plus que ses formes à
la non lieu alors il ya eu des coups 1
c'est un peu la vente qu'on avait montré
en fait les jours
ouais c'est la partie ça va faire nul
très très rapidement ici au
jeu longtemps
parce que ils menacent tomber sept
ont mais il a dû trouver ding le truc le
plus chiant agents pratique après j'ai
pas de doute car aux navarrais va la
sauver mais il va pas faire nul
maintenant maintenant
j'aime bien comment vous profitez du
temps de shenzhen pour alimenter youtube
bah ouais non mais en fait là on te fais
un truc qui est bien pour toi aussi qui
suit ici enfin je veux dire par là que
c'est pas une mauvaise chose paraît ce
que tu me résumer était plutôt content
de le voir les ventes de man toujours
est le résumé d'un parti qui s'est passé
à voir ta les raisins ont pas mais il ya
des gens qui sont arrivés maintenant qui
attend l'ouverture au moins ils ont vu
la partie quoi au lieu de te dire ah ben
là c'est nul on se fait chier parce que
c'est une qu'à la fin je sais que c'est
nul bien le dire c'est un jeu une
mineure et de s'ennuyer ont pas montré
un truc sympa pendant pendant pendant
cinq six minutes
comme on se joue à 15 heures ça commence
à 15h way et aujourd'hui ça paraît trop
trop longtemps greta arrivé
[Rires]
j'ai très peur quad femme li byd
n'en reste pas trop théorique ne voit
pas trop dans la rue calcule bien
je le vois pas perdre mais à burning ça
serait débile le faire nul maintenant il
a encore un avion plus pas autant qu'ils
soient complètement bloqué qu'il ait
plus aucune chance même même s'il sait
que a priori ces compromis digne m
sait-on jamais
mamane ces faits qui fait
briller les cas de figure où peut-être
qu'il va les bouffer un pion sur le
droit et va perdre c'est à la place pour
un quatre contre trois ça peut encore
durer
même si un côté intéressant dans son
ennui cette finale c'est que le jour où
on peut avoir une finale comme ça a joué
c'est à dire tiens commanding essaie de
poser des problèmes parce que nous on va
pas je contre caruana
du coup de voir qu'on lui laisse est de
gagner on peut retenir est comme ça des
fois contre le camp adversaire plus
accessible bas peut-être qu'on va gagner
en suivant le branding donc un petit
intérêt quoi
hayami chat qui est venu lui faire des
bisous
des qui jappe de riches à ces assises a
réuni c'est l'heure à laquelle arrive il
y en a plus ou moins là donc ça réveille
des envies qu'est ce qu'ils font tu n'as
pas de montre comment tu fais pour
savoir comment les deux les deux qu'on
vous ils sont encore assis devant leurs
emmerdes
déjà remarqué qu'ils étaient très habile
en cas d'égalité à la fin une sorte de
goal avérage particulier on a départagé
département c'est direct des partages je
sais pas quelle forme adobe deux parties
rapides ou je sais pas quoi puis dépit
de mes cd partage ce qui est pas main
mais je suis pas trop pour le
hadj particulier
en fait chaque à des partages à son
inconvénient mais
la même s'ils sont trois ils refont un
tournoi en fait il faut pas non plus
s'ils sont
406 ex-aequo ça va après la difficulté
qu'ils ont que c'est que ça peut être
infinie comme ils ont peur des trucs
infinie non mais oui je sais je sais
c'est pour ça qu'ils ne font pas ce que
des morts subites ils le font parce que
ça va être fini donc on est ou peut être
à finir ah oui et un match de tennis en
fait un jeu de tennis premier jeu c'est
infini des règles que vous comment
davantage d'égalité avantage égalitaire
ont des qualités jamais quoi et pourtant
le jeu existe depuis des années s'est
jamais arrive ça va quoi vous étiez
qu'ils ont toujours très peur de ça donc
on fait servi
ouais mais nakanishi et
c'est en train de revenir je vous avais
bien dit
demain cornetto va nous faire un bout
résume m ah bah oui granules s'est ainsi
fait pas les 12 tirs il fait
peut-être qu'il a à dire soit dans des
dykes gagnent parce que déjà c'est son
ouverture la rue voisine oui maintenant
mais sûrement un terrier je crois que
rona sont calés à 5 sur une nouveauté
donc
ça peut avoir à dire en termes
d'ouverture
à il va réussir ça il y avait une pub
jules nike avec son prince et agassi m'a
jamais des mois qui jouait les à la
barbe qui pousse ah oui oui c'est une
vieille plus vrai
oui c'est pour ça qu'on ne peut pas
à temps il a peut-être quelque chose
pour ses sept tours h 8
kg à perdre
1,4 contre
cet orage s'être
g6 pour éviter tout risque
j'espère toujours chargé
six minutes 27 pour l'analyse express
records du monde battus
on a fait 6000 27 un
levier qui va m'envoyer à
la vidéo qu'on va pouvoir mettre en
ligne immédiatement pour blesser leur
dif ouais ouais bah c'est une redif quoi
oui
avec l'europe viaduc à 33
rediff aide
c'est sympa ces titres vifs
en vrai je trouve que le format est pas
si cons en fait j'aime pas en fait du
coup c'est le format que j'aime pas
c'est le format de bas qui font tous en
fait entre 13 et 17 minutes
rien du tout ou tu montes des ventes
mais que c'est vrai qu'ils s'attardent
fournit pas les evans du coup sont
souvent fausses parce qu'ils font ça sur
le genou comme on est en russe par
analyser profondeur 25 donc à sa aucun
intérêt pour ce qui est dit en ouverture
ça aucun intérêt pour les mêmes pas
cours et s'est même pas couru du coup je
pense que ce format là où tu dis
vraiment enfin tu vas au bout tu assumes
vraiment à 100% le truc en fait
toi tu pense pareil tu dis
non mais moi j'aime bien moi je suis
d'accord avec son
analyse
bah oui mais si on analyse pour nice
pourra pas prétendre analysé en disant
de la merde avec des bandes de coûts
très profond tu sais on contrôle bien le
centre matt schaub a invoqué non
non mais oui maintenant toi tu parle
d'échec se parle pas d'échec et voilà
moi c'est assumé dans les deux
mais ça ressemble plus à un format alors
j'ai pas envie dire télé parce que ce
sera encore un peu trop long mais
vraiment former informer infosport tu
qu'un jour tu vois c'est un peu quand tu
regardes et
tu vois tout le sport ouais c'est ça
tous les appels au micro résumé ouais
j'ai marqué j'ai vu le micro régime et
de saint-etienne nice quand vous aviez
perdu à dire oui des deux roues et
freins coup franc puis cats auraient en
fait c'est pour ça que j'ai appelé à
prix s'est passé quoi être tu as vu le
match mais juge que mes 2 0 est plus
dans le coup et avoue 4 2
et même en fait je comprends je suis
comme toi en fait je comprends les deux
formats le très long et très court enfin
ce qu'on fait mais je comprends pas le
truc intermédiaire ta ni l'un ni l'autre
en fait née saint barbe et le très court
battu prétend pas analysé c'est plus
informatif en fait ouais je t'informe tu
dis tiens voilà c'est passé comme ci
comme ça à mon avis tu es bien puis là
une connerie puis été mal puis l'a perdu
bon ok bravo hein c'est bon tu sais ce
qui s'est passé soit ta intéressait
vraiment par les variantes par l'analyse
théorique le machin est là bas tu te
poses et tu passes une demi-heure dessus
ou plus bah oui c'est vrai que ces trucs
dibril au mieux
nos rempli aucun des trucs donne une
illusion de le faire
oui c'est ça
ma espérons qu'on réussit ça
a créé un
un nouveau format
peut-être qu'ils vont nous copier
away alex ya pas mal de vidéos entre 13
et 7 8 sur 10 stream des genres nouvelle
topaloff en fait c'est des parties ou
nuls théorie qui s'est passé dans la
partie juste de base serait pas une
partie qui ont été sur big prime s'ils
ont cherché à juste une partie
intéressante à mettre mais c'étaient des
partisans du stream parce qu'on suivait
muet l'otan richesse en soi la partie à
la reine intéressant à part le fait de
suiveurs tonne maxime bah oui donc là
pour le poster une vidéo à titre
informatif mais il n'y a rien de plus à
dire toi tu vas pas parler d'une heure
d'une partie nuls en 30 coups et toutes
les pièces échangées
le diras tu repas donné un faux suspense
et être long pour être long jonathan qui
est pour aujourd'hui il ya quand même
pas mal de ventes à voir qu'est ce qui
se passe il va [ __ ] en f1 et ce qui se
passe si près un fils avec l'autre
cavaliers qu'est-ce qui se poste qui
était bien là mais c'est tout ce qui est
des 6èmes des trucs avoir fait ce qu'il
fait froid je suis un coup avant un coup
après ok mais là en fait tu dois passer
du temps et analysé quoi
ben oui oui
donc là et des trucs à dire il est parti
il ya rien à dire par exemple
peut-être que rapporte nakaya pas grand
chose à dire la tronche de la partie
serait pas une partie qu'on choisirait
de m en temps normal la
balle mais bon les gens ont toujours te
prendre l'exemple d'une part qu'on a
fait jusqu'à dire qu'on l'a juste fait
pour montrer ce qu'elle veut elle
faisait et long terme et toi aussi tu
[Musique]
es ce que je veux juste tellement je
vais rien joué du tout cet été je veux
jouer
non allant du 4 septembre tournant aux
canaris vont soit rien du tout c'était
ses commentaires ses vacances stages
le tage à lisbonne avec m d'ailleurs si
vous êtes toujours intéressé il reste
quelques places qu'on pourra pas bloquer
les champs encore très longtemps
vraiment on devrait tous bloqués
jusqu'au 1er juin on arrive à donner
demander un petit délai les gens sont
intéressés
encore temps d'ailleurs jusqu'à la fin
des candidats mais non rester là on
prend encore un peu chaque jour et puis
mois après j'ai enchaîné avec un stage
vers barcelone avec maso et puis ce sera
déjà
out
qui aura le petit tournant aux canaries
a priori
pas trop trop
bien clichy avec axel exactement au bon
c'est pas trop mal débrouillé
sans faire de génial mais on a fait 3e
c'est plutôt pas mal vu la concurrence
moi je trouve pas que j'ai très bien
joué je n'ai pas perdu
est à peu près
aucun énoncé pas un gros tournant ce
soit en
attendant extra pas super forme elle a
quand même quelques kilomètres après pas
il fera beau moi j'aime mieux je ne vois
que j'aime bien
j'aimerais que tu aimes pas voilà ben
sahar est à un moment très motivé
mais en fait
vous aussi pour voyager voir des gens et
faire des trucs je jouais en soit
ça t'intéresse pas
donc la finale va être nul pour ces les
joueurs de ce niveau là le 4 contre 3
c'est assez facile ont déjà vous en
parler après si vous êtes intéressé faut
juste ouvrir des livres de finale on
peux pas vous expliquer
comment il faut dire que roy touré pions
contre roye tour ça fait nul et que en
gros tous les pions s'échanger qu'on va
rester avec un pion et une tour contre
un roi et une tour et que ça c'est nul
parce que le roi va te
ventures' droits des noirs et à l'ouest
là bas sur la dame on a quelque chose
gagnant pour les blancs parce que le roi
pourrait pas venir bloquer le pion mais
là
là ici avec laurent f6 bah oui
c'est vu un candide s'élever
mais moins pour moi il manque de
pratique en fait digne basse
parce que les positions il les a en
quelque sorte et lave pas les gagnants
un petit doute ouais
et le doute se confirme
exemple fait pas les stages en france
ça c'est cher les hôtels en france
après on a hésité quand même en asie des
deux
cas il ya deux ans
ok la location
souvent l'étranger tu peux avoir des
offres
ah oui on pourrait faire en france
d'ailleurs les stages sur un week-end
seulement avec celle à paris récemment
on
l'a enfin en france sur des week-ends
et là en plein été sur une semaine tu à
lisbonne on va voir peut-être en
personne ou 30 et 40
évident d'art des prix qu en france
ouais il ya aussi le côté c'est un aussi
un peu moi qui ai push pour ça en f1
comme en cinq ans j'ai fait deux
semaines de vacances voilà bien une
histoire card scène ça permet aussi de
faire un truc tu assez sympa moi je suis
très content de le faire ce stage mais
c'est vrai que du coup mise à part mon
studio et me stream je vois pas grand
chose du monde quoi au moins
leur voiture dans le mans ouais on va
visiter on fera du en fera t on fera un
blog sur le chemin et puis ça permet de
[Musique]
je veux dire après ça tu as en face à
des belges il l'a 10 bonnes c'est très
cool enfin cette vie là j'ai entendu que
du bien pas moi je suis déjà allé en
fait je dire java jee won main stage la
voiture a trop bien c'est une super
victoire
donc ouais c'est pas un hourra pourri
non plus qu'on a choisi
bonne c'est bien ça va faire une semaine
de vacances
travail échec ça permet de progresser en
jambes la commune enfin moi c'est plutôt
cool parce qu'on fera du ca basse est
fait pour alors moi non on fait pas
c'est pas mon truc mais les gens sont
bien évidemment les bienvenues pourront
faire s'il veut
ça va être ça va être sympa
ça va être sympa on va s'amuser je suis
en train de faire ma mise en main mise
de près la mise en ligne de la vidéo est
réalisée lors de ce stage
se passer un bon moment travailler échec
donc il y avait un petit problème la fin
d'an après des choses
mais de passer aussi un bon moment et
humains et de vacances dans un cadre
coule
pas de faire 15 heures d'échec dans la
journée
certains trucs sont intéressés et
bienvenue aux nombreux repas tous
pourris qu'on dit
voilà tu vois c'est un truc que j'aime
bien faire moi j'aime bien entrer les
gens en réel
et encore plus sous ce format là de
blond
là j'aime bien les petits week-ends ça
va mais c'est sympa si tu l'as tu as
vraiment le temps de faire quoi
ouais mais il ya des gens qui meurent en
trouvant les autres stages et tous et
qui on s'entend bien après moi je suis
pour rien c'était j'obtiendrai voir avec
qui j'aimerais faire des trucs mais
c'est arrivé j'ai jamais de temps mais
toi du coup tu as pu plus
fragiles ou par exemple si leur église
ne nous regarde c'est dur de voir mais
toi tu as pu aller le voir et tout et je
suis super content qu'ils reviennent on
va le revoir à lisbonne et on s'est créé
assez souvent mais à mais pas qu'eux
mais
voilà on a revu nos amis ouais ouais
j'ai vu c'est un bon exemple en plus ce
n'est pas tout les deux églises où
il a écrit hier soir encore ou peut-être
ou peut-être même tout à l'heure ce
qu'on fait il est passé de rugby où
il n'était pas bien d'ailleurs
après la défaite du stade toulousain
contre les castrais valeureux ans les
castrer
finale du top 14
castres montpellier et toulouse a peur
d'eux
ouais bah ouais mais bon les valeureux
dans les castrer ses rangs les valeurs
de l'ovalie tu valenciennes encore
qu'ils ont peu changé style de jeu mais
bon ça passe par devant tu vois ça passe
pas par
le ballon ne va pas chanter sur les
ailes normalement côté calcium un fou
comme ça après ils ont quand même des
beaux joueurs ils ont peut-être rory
kockott que tu connais même s'il est
maintenant un peu âgée a été dominé
l'équipe de france est au tapis et a
bon joueur argentin qui est un superbe
jeu au pied médias je suis passé de
rugby aux diplômes quoi se rendre au
château ouais tu voyais des bourgs
surtout qu'à coupe du monde l'an
prochain mais il va falloir les gas gas
et c'est déjà tout plein voir ça
ouais ouais ouais non faut construire
des places pour nice ya des matches à
nice tu sais pas comment à romanel aussi
faut qu'on casse les blacks crois qu'on
joue françois blaquart match de match
d'ouverture
je dis pas de conneries tu peux
ouais c'est pas grave de perf en groupe
c'est sur de plus ou moins sûr de sortir
les montes a pas envie de se les prendre
un des premiers matches le
moins du coup
la vidéo la vidéo ben écoute je vais
pouvoir la sortir
jusque ce soir on
c'est à dire bien ouais ça va ça passe
ça passe ça passe ah ouais ça passe
[Musique]
on va dire
ce que je la mets sur twitter oui
pourquoi pas
est-ce qu'en grèce
je retrouve comme ça
bon
finale
qui devra ensuite sharks n'ont
en fait je sais pas tu vas pas sûr qu'on
voit souvent
cgh
à la poêle différentes
[Musique]
je sais pas trop où sont les chances ou
pas du tout
j'avais la résidence spectateurs tu vas
voir un peu ce qui se passe mais je n'ai
pas trop grandir mon rôle c'est un essai
surtout qui avec tous ces chiens là ça
c'est bon mais peut-être qu'il veut
tenter
way a lâché 4 où tu ramènes là tout
autour
du tc change écrit
j'ai changé mais
pas d'essai j'ai cinq tours h1 et h5
donc pas juste le bloquer mécaniquement
mento ranger 4
je passe par des oui en fait même se
fait d un g1 quentin et mangé un jeu
suit angers 4
ouais en fait en tout cas il va pas
lâcher la proie comme ça
il va falloir
donc il nous fais à oui mais il a fait
retour des quatre géants
mais s'il peut faire g5 g4
fautif et g5 h5 g4 d'attaqué peuvent
jamais trop partir de sa cage
bages et 5 c'est peut-être le très bon
coup